end of limbo week we're taking tomorrow
off we're not going to be working we're
going to be we're going to be
celebrating we're going to be having a
work party and then just having a good
New Year's Eve I hope all of you will be
doing the same so thank you for joining
us on this Thursday evening it is
Thursday right uh we're gonna have a
good time we got some crazy news
um the Epstein guards had their criminal
charges dropped because it's a cover-up
they're doing all of this on the holiday
for during the holiday for a reason
because people aren't paying attention
ratings are real low people aren't even
working I think Tucker Carlson's on
vacation uh people just not watching the
news it's a perfect time to do it but uh
it's also the end of limbo week so we're
we're just going to be chilling we'll be
hanging out talking about I guess the
news or whatever we're hanging out with
own cook
thanks man uh yeah Owen Cook um I teach
pers personal growth and
self-development we've done live events
in 265 cities and 75 countries around
the world hundreds of thousands of
people face to face and millions online
and so we just thought we'd bring in
that perspective cool we'll be chilling
what's that
well it's another day and yet another
major cover-up of an international
trafficking and extortion operation by
the intelligence agencies yeah I got a
lot to go off on uh just just get me
started but before we begin I definitely
wanted to shout out Aaron Rodgers he
came out and publicly said that if
science can't be questioned it's
propaganda and he is absolutely right he
also talked about what the NFL is doing
secretly I think we're going to be
talking about that I got so much I want
to get into but uh the phrase that Aaron
Rodgers said is something that of course
I personally believe in that's why a
couple months ago I made this shirt
saying that if you could question it if
it's science if it's not if you can't
it's propaganda you could get yours
exclusively on the best
politicalshirts.com and because you do
I'm here thank you so much for having me
this should be a really interesting
conversation to say the least
you know Luke it's his rants just like
that that gives me flashbacks to like
when you first started red pilling me
with your rants on timcast this is the
pre-ramp no no no
I'm fired up though I'm locking loaded
I'm ready to go but this is the pre
loaded up means something different
viewers of our show last night would
understand that yeah of course uh Chris
Carr executive editor at timcast.com uh
although I am technically Chris Carr I'm
very much feeling the energy of Ian as I
sit in his chair and uh taking his all
of his crystals yeah can people there's
there's no way from the sea there's
literally like no two dozen crystals in
front of me at all you really just kind
of have to see the display for
yourselves but it's very powerful
polished spherical pyrite I believe and
gems and um I'll take a photo of it
right now and put it on Twitter just so
people see the amount of rocks that are
amount of laid in front of you and Magic
hippie stuff that's a beautiful thing
Luke's got machetes yes damn right you
never know things get crazy here on this
show and they do I'm ready so well it
gets wild yeah then then everyone can
know that uh Owen was here invited by
Luke actually
this is my third guest I'm like
time I'm not that goddamn
we'll see I am also here in the corner
and pushing buttons having fun I was
saying earlier that the crystals and the
machetes right here in front of me are
like yin and yang so we're trying to
keep the peace but we have the means to
do it I'm excited look for the show
let's go before we get started my
friends go over to timcast.com become a
member help support all of our
journalism the website is almost I would
say it's like 99.9 funded just by
members like there's there's some other
revenue streams but basically all the
journalists we have good people like
Chris Chris Carr here they're funded by
you guys as members so if you think we
do a good job reporting on this stuff
covering like say the Epstein case the
Maxwell trial then you can support our
work by being a member of course we have
a massive library of content including
the Green Room guests before the show
that goes up periodically and then we
have of course the Tim cast iron members
only exclusives so again support our
work but you can also go to timcast.com
click the store and pick up our very new
don't be that guy be a gorilla shirt we
thought long and hard about how to make
merch about this one so I pinned it in
the in the chat room on YouTube because
we didn't want it to be negative I I
didn't want to make a t-shirt that
mimified a negative moment and insulted
anybody and so we were like do we wanna
I'm not that guy's shirt I'm not that
guy I'm a gorilla because the gorilla
Meme and I was like I don't know if
people would understand that and so I
was like how about don't be that guy be
a gorilla I like that right and so
that's what we made so it still
references some kind of me moment but we
want it to be positive and silly and
funny and not kind of down and negative
so again you can go to timcast.com in
the store and pick that up don't forget
to like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really do like it let's talk
about the news and I gotta say um we got
the story from tibgas.com criminal case
against Epstein's prison guards dropped
on Thursday just one day after gizzling
Maxwell is convicted of sex trafficking
the charges against Epstein's prison
guards are dropped now yesterday my
friends I pointed out after reading the
headline that we would be demonetized
because when a story is this big and
this important there's no point in
trying to dance around it we will be
demonetized and then of course I threw
it over to Luke and Luke just went off
and so we'll we'll carry on with that
new tradition Luke this criminal
cover-up is reaching its epidemic to the
point where it's epidemic what you know
what I'm trying to say here are you
freaking kidding me like the guard the
guards that were sleeping falsifying
records the people that were responsible
for the the
[Laughter]
for the extermination oh let's just
let's just say Jeffrey Epstein
was left alone in his cell by sleeping
guards and then later was found not
alive anymore India yes
whatever you may call it some people
like to name it a part of a someone who
was running as a presidential candidate
but that's another thing but these
guards were caught napping they were
caught allegedly looking up the news
they were caught looking uh for
motorcycles and furniture and other
expensive items where they were doing
well they falsified the records here and
there were the ones that were supposed
to be doing the rounds checking on
Epstein making sure that of course he
did not hurt himself in any way shape or
form and of course they absolutely
failed on that job what happened to
Epstein no one knows the video footage
of his first alleged attempt to hurt
himself was literally
destroyed and not found under the hands
of the authorities that of course later
came out with the statement by James
comey's daughter and said oh no we just
we just lost the tapes we don't know
what happened there was of course a
second attempt attempt whatever may
happen we don't know because again these
guards were allegedly too busy looking
to buy motorcycles to find out so again
the evidence here is being once again
destroyed and the fact that these guards
had their charges dropped by the federal
government shows you just how complicit
how disgusting how rotten the system is
and how they want you to forget this
very important story the story of the
decade when the mainstream media was
promoting Jeffrey Epstein as some kind
of great philanthropist they were
promoting him at some kind of big money
guy a Wall Street guy a hedge fund guy
everyone including even miss McCain knew
that he was up to extremely awful
horrible things and everyone within the
government knew what he was doing the
FBI knew since the 90s and they were
sitting on their hands as thousands of
children were being hurt and literally
sacrificed at the altar for the ruling
Elites to do whatever they wanted to in
horrible disgusting ways and I got a lot
more to say about this and Princess was
connected to this but you got to say
something I got to say something very
important for everybody who's listening
to this segment
the reason this story is dropping just
before New Year's Eve viewership is
going to be down across the board
ratings are going to be down everyone's
on vacation no one's paying attention
they are covering this up they sealed
the records the trial was rushed through
we we got a glimpse through a keyhole
there was more evidence the FBI had and
apparently was cataloged that's never
got been gone through and now they're
saying with the records being resealed
all of these high profile individuals
were flying on this plane never gonna
find out about it they dropped the trial
the conviction comes just after
Christmas
they're dropping the criminal charges
against the guards in the prison where
Epstein lost his life
and it's happening on during a holiday
it is it is you do this this is this is
a PR Dead Zone okay companies release
information the news comes out on Friday
nights or during holidays to make sure
no one sees it now I don't have all the
answers this is but but people you need
to make sure that people hear this story
because as big as it was when we heard
Epstein was no longer alive in his
prison cell this story the story the
guards are having their charges drop
needs to be just as big and we're
fighting a a massive 30-foot wall from
sea to shining sea keeping this
information out and that is releasing it
on a holiday this is absolutely a
criminal cover-up and nothing else what
else can you can you say here why did
the government say hey these people that
are responsible for thousands of
children never getting Justice these
guards that are responsible for these
men that hurt children in unspeakable
ways never facing Justice these guards
are the ones responsible for it they
have so much Weighing on on their
decisions that night and they're not
going to be held responsible for one of
the biggest injustices in our legal
justice system I mean Epstein was in the
hands of the authorities they had
everything he would have spoken he would
have leaked names he had the profiles he
had the DVDs he had the CDs he had the
hard drives on so many prominent
individuals that of course he surveilled
he had so much blackmail so much power
so much truth and the federal government
is squashing it making sure you will
never see it and that is utterly
disgusting because your tax dollars your
ignorance literally allowed some of the
worst human atrocities to happen on the
face of this Earth that were sanctioned
stamped on by the approval of the
federal authorities by the police
officers the prosecutors the judges the
politicians The Regulators all of them
were involved here and this system is
rotten to its core and to see this major
story break now on on a Thursday right
before New Year's this is deliberate
this didn't happen today by the way
people need to understand this happened
some unknown time ago and now we're
we're finding out about it it's
absolutely crazy oh do you want to say
that well the thing that I think about
in issues like this is why has Society
become so apathetic what is it I mean oh
this is a little bit you know tangential
but like what is it in our food system
that makes us so apathetic towards us
what is it about our day-to-day boring
drive to work that makes us so apathetic
sugar and yeah
and like what is it about the you know
the the over stimulation that we see in
society that makes us not care about
this so and then from that standpoint if
you can kind of pull out a little bit
what could the average person even do
let's say that this had broken during a
peak news cycle what could the average
person even do about it to where they're
not so demoralized that they just sit
there and go I don't know what do you
want me to do but then they just get
back to the to the bread and circus you
know I was just thinking we should do a
skit like the movie don't look up so in
the movie you know I guess spoiler alert
it's not that big of a spoiler because
if you know if you read what the movie's
about it's just people saying like
there's a there's a meteor a comma gonna
hit the earth and they go on they go on
TV and the people on TV you're like
uh-huh I think that would be it would be
fascinating to have a similar sketch
where it's like Luke goes on a talk show
and he's like powerful Global Elites are
flying on these planes including the
former president to two former
presidents you've got the one of the
wealthiest men in the world there are
children being trafficked and they're
like that's so crazy how can I get one
of these flights I think that has just
happened that's right you know yeah no
no no that's a that's an excellent idea
even for a funny skit video instead of
the asteroid coming to destroy Earth
it's a whole bunch of like hopped up
billionaires that are ready to like do
horrible things it's small children and
there's an epidemic of them going wild
literally having their way and doing
them hurting children like 50 Bill Gates
marching through the streets right
Bill Gates gets a mutation device where
he replicates and there's thousands of
them and they're all going on and like
like a pandemic of the zombies but
instead of zombies they do other
unspeakable things especially to little
children and then there's no future and
then we can make this like a no future
because there's no more children because
the Bill Gates is and the other horrible
people have other ways with them but
there's also a lot of other important
details here that we got to talk about
with prince Andrew I'll say one more
thing and I'll throw it to you on prince
Andrew I just want to let people know
that when Luke wakes up in the morning
well I shouldn't say in the morning when
Luke wakes up just around the crack of
noon yeah and he's very groggy and tired
and I'm like I gotta get this guy
whipped into shape there's actually one
magic word I can say to make it so that
Luke instantly is in 110 he's like
walking around he's in his pajamas and
he's like I'm tired man you got any
coffee on the go Epstein
and then he just goes off and he's 100
I'm like he's ready for the day how in
the world can you not about that this is
pretty important what you just said
there so if you when you study spiritual
girl there's books like uh Power okay
power versus Force um that you can look
up and they talk about how one of the
lowest levels in human consciousness is
apathy right and the next level above
that is anger and so in many ways I
think the mainstream media plays into
that where if somebody's in an apathetic
mode and then you put a story about love
or peace or Joy or fun that doesn't
resonate what energizes Us in like in my
little thing that I do I call it a derp
State basically this apathetic Derpy
state that most of us are in and they
will have to fight our way out of
um what happens is that the media knows
that makes people angry and so we're
kind of stuck in this thing where it's
hard to get people to that next level
right so in spiritual growth you know if
you've ever read Eckhart Tolle he calls
his second book is called a new Earth
you know and a lot of people talk about
that like what would a better world
actually look like and when most of us
are eating the wrong foods and we're
spaced out and we're in apathy and then
you hear about Jeffrey Epstein I mean
let's be like I loved your point you
said Tim and I took a huge amount of
Knowledge from that but then I honestly
do wonder even if that had been posted
on a major Newsday would anything have
even happened I mean it is so much in
your face I'm probably more Widow well
well I'll say this man I think it was a
big red pill moment for a lot of
Americans yes when the dude was no
longer alive in his prison cell we'll
just we'll say it that way because
no he was just he was just he was there
and then all of a sudden he was no
longer alive whatever you wanted
whatever you want to say about it the
point is
a lot of people were just like whoa and
so that may not have a direct effect on
will they go outside and protest but
it'll probably have a big impact on what
they read in the news and could shift
culture very very much so I like to say
taken out because there's many
interpretations where you could kind of
allude to what happened here but this is
a key linchpin story that that has a lot
of people's confidence in the entire
system hanging in the balance because
people understand if your system if
you're tax dollars if you're police
officers you're judges your prosecutors
are literally out there participating
aiding and abetting or looking the other
way as children or being hurt in
unspeakable ways that's a system that
does not have any trust within it and
this is why the when this story broke
there was a huge response to this not by
the corporate media not even about big
Tech social media people had to force
the hashtag Jeffrey Epstein didn't blank
himself that hashtag went almost
everywhere corporate media was forced to
cover it and and the the kind of veil
surrounding this entire system started
to unfold because people started to see
how people how things really work in
Washington DC you know that bill that's
very popular populist policies that
never get passed why don't they get
passed what power do these special
interests have what extortion abilities
what blackmail do they have for these
politicians to always turn their back on
the citizens and never delivered on
their promises well we got a sneak peek
at it we got a small window we got the
tip of the iceberg with Jeffrey Epstein
and the rabbit hole goes a lot deeper uh
now so what can the average person do
about this their attention their energy
just even understanding this is
extremely powerful because the system
can't function if if not enough people
believe in them right so oh God no no I
was just going to say that like that
that's something that's really bothering
me too that's you keep iterating the
same question I keep thinking it's just
like okay so what what can you do what
can the average person do yes being red
pilled on this whole story is pretty
important but maybe at some level it
would help people feel like they could
um sort of if they see this on the
national level and they see how deep it
is and how corrosive the whole system
can be and with an issue like this then
maybe it would make them think well I
can't let this happen at the local level
you know I mean if because like they
can't do anything about Manhattan if
they're in the midwest somewhere but
they could be aware of wow if it could
happen there then it can happen here and
they're going to do whatever they can to
get engaged in local politics and local
school school boards and figure out ways
to make sure that there's accountability
when bad stuff happens it's it's not
just about voting it's not just about
getting involved or anything like that
if one day let's just put this way let's
say tomorrow we woke up and literally
every single person in this country was
actively against critical race Praxis in
schools it'll be gone because all of a
sudden even Democrats would be like we
are going to lose because people are so
strongly against this
everybody who heard that story about
these prison guards and immediately
regular people who are not in politics
were like yo what the just happened
that's a moment where people might just
say very simply I'm not going to put
money towards certain things I'm going
to read different news sources it can
cause such a major cultural shift that I
think an important point that Luke
brought up is confidence in a system is
the only way the system can function so
if one day everybody woke up and felt
that the US dollar had no value it would
literally have no value so when people
get this news it changes their
perception it can strip confidence away
from the system that's why they put it
out just before New Year's Eve when
nobody's paying attention and if the
government cared about you or your
children or just innocent children at
all they wouldn't went to those guards
and they would have said okay what
happened here did you really just fall
asleep were you really buying furniture
here were you buying a motorcycle here
or did something else happen we're gonna
put pressure on you you're gonna face a
very stiff sentence for this dereliction
of Duty because you just created
Injustice for thousands of children they
didn't do any of that they just
mysteriously someday before this dropped
the charges when did they drop the
charges we don't know because again a
lot of this as Tim is saying was
specifically scheduled in a way so not
enough people know about this they're
afraid of more people finding out about
this and and this is why if the feds
really cared about you they would have
went to Maxwell and they would have been
like okay you were the procurer who did
you procure who to who else was in this
who else was involved here who else were
you hanging out here tell us and we'll
give you a lesser sentence one of those
individuals admittedly is the man who
doesn't sweat at all doesn't have any
sweat glands according to him is of
course Mr prince Andrew the Queen's son
the queens and and the royal family have
a lot of connections to really awful
people who do very similar things that
Epstein did by the way the Epstein is
not the first person connected to the
royal family that does these awful
horrible things real quick there's a
picture of Epstein and Maxwell at the
Queen's Cottage yep there's a picture of
Kevin Spacey and Elaine Maxwell sitting
on the throne are you kidding me how
many of these people are interconnected
the way that I think about it okay when
you're in a business basically the way
most businesses function is you keep
gradually increasing the price and then
what you do is you tend to shrink what
it is that you're giving and then you
wait until customer stop buying right so
there was freedoms that were one for us
by people largely in the past and what
happened is is that the establishment
can begin to infringe on those freedoms
or even flaunt this nonsense in our face
and as long as there's no boundary that
will keep going right because if you're
in a business and then you just keep
raising the price or raising the price
you're like they're just going to let us
keep raising the price they say you sell
orange juice you keep giving less and
less orange juice the point is like one
drop right and then you're like they're
gonna buy a drop for a hundred dollars
well do it for do it for a thousand
dollars then and so what's happening is
that back in the day when the kind of
people lived in our society who would
have had some kind of a boundary they
can't just push the envelope like they
have in 2020 like they have with Epson
all this different kind of stuff but I
look at myself so you know me and Luke
are friends and I've been listening to
what he's saying for Years Tim I've
watched what you're saying for years and
I'm like I was like okay I'm Soul what
do I do right and it's like I don't know
what to do so talk to people and I and I
do and I make videos about it and I have
a new video series about it and all that
kind of stuff but I just
like when I'm teaching this seminar for
example in personal growth what we try
to do is get people to buy into this
idea that they should improve and then
we give them a direction on what to do
for somebody who so for me watching this
it's like what me watching a seminar
with this incredible Theory but what do
you do so I love how people say it yeah
you tell more people about it because
like I I think confidence in a system is
the most important thing taking it away
if if people aren't paying attention and
don't care the criminals get away with
it but if you uh if you've got if you've
got 100 people and they all have their
backs turned to a bank the bank robber
is like now's my chance if you tell hey
everybody turn around and they all do
the guy's gonna be like
um I'm not gonna do this everybody's
watching now yeah I mean that's one way
to put it once everyone's paying
attention it makes it very difficult for
criminals to get away with this stuff
it's because people get mad people vote
people don't buy things it breaks
confidence in the system if every single
person in this country was focused on
this story right now and believed
something wrong was happening the
politicians would be sweating bullets
they could only get away with it if
people are not paying attention to what
they're doing when with that attention
it is leading to some circumstances
Elaine Maxwell awful person according to
all her accusers is going away Jeffrey
Epstein no longer here if we were
totally blind to this entire situation
that operation would have been going on
VH VH 1 was making documentary pieces
about how great Epstein was how much
money he had and people were falling for
that trap and there was people coming to
him with their children be like yeah
you're cool we want to hang out not
knowing that this is a big monster that
will hurt you that the more we know
about these monsters there's a reason
Bill Gates spends hundreds of millions
of dollars buying off the corporate
media literally he sent I think 319
million dollars all over the corporate
media he does that because without
people's ignorance he can't get away
with a lot of the stuff that he's doing
and he's rarely ever he was asked I
think once or twice about his connection
to of course Jeffrey Epstein that's a
far bigger extensive uh connection here
his response to it was atrocious his
response to it was even more surprising
that even the question being asked the
first time but but again this story
doesn't end and I just before Rihanna I
want to talk about prince Andrew because
this also is the breaking of the damn of
this entire establishment system that is
so uh disgusting and has so much
blackmail in it because Andrew's lawyers
are now holding emergency talks there's
the the the victim's defense lawyer who
said that Andrew should be shaking in
his boots he just filed a motion to make
sure that all of the witness testimony
including his deposition is kept secret
from the general public this has never
been heard from before he's facing a
civil suit in the United States he's
making a lot of outlandish arguments
we're still waiting for him to be
deposed and when he's deposed he's going
to be sitting there in front of the
lawyers representing the victims the
children here that were hurt here and
he's going to have to answer some
serious questions and there's a lot of
them including how the Royal protection
officers literally destroyed evidence to
his Alibi there is a lot of dirty
disgusting things happening here and
it's only our ability to talk about it
get it out there that is able to stop a
lot of this in its tracks and it did
work in some way it's it's hard to it's
hard to move on from the story because
I'm really quite offended that they're
putting it out right now and it's
obvious why that's why I've brought it
up so much so please guys if you're
hearing this keep this fresh in your
mind keep it keep a tab open in your
browser with the story and get ready to
share it in the next week or so to let
people know you got to pay attention to
this stuff because these are these are
evil people doing evil things but one
last thing one last thing I'm sorry I
just have a million things I want to say
but I just really quickly this also
Bridges the gap between the left and the
right people on the left agree people on
the right agree what happened here in
this specific instant is an absolute
horrible case of government out of
control that is absolutely unaccountable
this is a potential item that could
bring us all together against that
powers that be that truly do run things
and truly make things miserable for us
and it shatters that Divine and Conquer
agenda that's why I talk about this so
much and I get so passionate about it
because it's so important let me let me
give a shout out to Hassan [ __ ] he's
got a tweet Hassan us at Hassan the hun
I responded with eight fire emojis he
said my thoughts are with the Clinton
family in this trying time as their
close and personal best friend picture
front and center at Chelsea Clinton's
wedding is going to federal prison for
sex trafficking minors and according to
one report I saw I haven't fact checked
this one apparently the wedding was like
invite only no strangers allowed so yeah
yeah this this does bring the left and
the right together very much so and
there's there's a viral tweet that a
tweet that went viral that was posted
all over Reddit and someone said if Joe
Biden was involved with Epstein then he
should go to prison if Donald Trump was
involved with Epstein he should go to
prison see was that so hard and I'm like
no it wasn't because literally everyone
agrees the left so there's people who
are trying to make it seem like Trump
supporters are like well Trump should
get away with it
everybody agrees release the documents
show us the book show us everybody show
us the tapes I don't care if they're on
the left or the right
that's it all the more reason to bury it
exit live week yeah Luke mentioned
divide and conquer so very much
important for the for the establishment
and this is the one thing that brings us
together and it scares the crap out of
the establishment it scares the crap out
of the corporate media they want this
story to go away this decision again I
have to say this again this decision
with the federal government dropping
these charges didn't happen today it
happened some other time we don't know
when it happened deliberately in a way
so we do not pay attention to it that
and and when they're doing all this you
know it's showing that that their
propaganda is extremely important for
everything that they're doing and it
could be stopped with the truth all
right well let's let's move on to the
next story okay it's really hard to get
away from that stuff it's so big it's so
important but um I saw a clip earlier
that maybe very maybe laugh a lot it was
from Steve bannon's war room and Bannon
said that Alex Jones was on the
Forefront of the transhumanism stuff
before everybody and then he shows a
clip of Alex from several years ago just
screaming that inter-dimensional demons
have possessed people and are sending
the message I just thought it was funny
I'm like I don't know I don't care I
mean whatever it was just it's funny to
watch and uh oh that that's I just
brought that up for no reason just to
mention that it was funny but we have
the story about Alex Jones Alex Jones
threatens to Dish dirt on a pathetic
Donald Trump for pushing vaccines and
tells his Infowars listeners to move on
from the Republican 2024 front runner
Alex Jones said Wednesday that he will
dish all the dirt on Donald Trump now
that the former president has come out
more definitively in favor of
vaccinations in fact maybe you know what
to get Trump's attention maybe I should
just dish all the dirt the far-right
media Personnel he said on Infowars
Jones said the impending gossip is not
to hurt Trump it's so people can know
how pathetic he is when you think he's
playing 4D chess Trump was booed by his
supporters early this month when he
revealed that he received the covid-19
booster shot but I just want to point
out Trump's always been in favor of this
Trump spearheaded the operation warp
speed campaign he's at his rallies
telling people to get it I don't
understand how this is new information
but I do think it's interesting I'm
wondering if you get what you guys think
on Alex Jones you know what happened
Trump had previously said you know he
was Pro vax but he was against oh Trump
was previously saying that he was
pro-vax but against the boosters
um and then he said he was against the
boosters
I think he was kind of like uh boosters
right and then he hit a point where he's
like I got the booster so it was more um
it was he was kind of walking it back a
little bit and then it seemed as though
he kind of is now more in favor of it
well it's definitely favorable at least
what I'm hearing from the Trump
supporters that I know is that he had
plausible deniability early on like he
wanted to just get out of a pandemic he
wanted to get out of lockdowns and
that's why he put an operation warp
speed into place and now that he sees it
as far insofar as I understand it he
sees the vaccine as his legacy that's
why he's at times so desperately trying
to make it his legacy but the Trump
supporters that I know are really angry
about this like I know we were talking
the other night and you said that most
of the people are just like oh you got
the booster so what but every Trump
supporter that I know they're furious at
the fact that he is still pushing it
after what they perceive to be there's
data that's come out that he should be
aware of and I don't know why he's not
aware of it didn't Trump say that it's
hard to criticize Biden now because
Biden congratulated him on the work he
did with the vaccine did he say that I
believe that I got a fact check it
really quickly but he's on the same side
of fauci fauci is also saying Donald
Trump is doing the right thing here and
singing Trump's Praises so uh when
you're on the same side as as Biden and
fauci and promoting a big Pharma out of
control unaccountable huge institution
that doesn't have any liability there
should be a lot of questions here and
what Donald Trump said wasn't backed by
science he didn't present any data he
didn't present any kind of evidence he
went off and talked in tangents and
generalizations about pushing a
narrative and agenda it was just a
generic mainstream media talking point
that didn't explain anything he said
you're going to die if you don't take
this essentially yes did Trump literally
say that um his points what did what was
his words exactly like
um we've got to look up we're talking
about the Bill O'Reilly interview right
no we're talking about the Candace Owens
interview oh so there's a number of
interviews where he's he's gone off and
talked about this uh so Donald Trump has
been extremely bullish on big Pharma
extreme really supportive of of you know
the Trump scene as he calls it and a lot
of people are like wait wait you know
where's the science where's the data at
least talk to us in a way where you
could convince us with information
you're not doing that you're kind of
speaking in general General platitudes
and people are like wait what's going on
here so that's the larger question
Donald Trump
wants credit for this
Geraldo said call it the Trump vaccine
give him credit for this Donald Trump
will never let this go and Donald Trump
cares more about the opinion of the New
York Times than his own constituents
yeah I think that was true with the
hiring of John Bolton with the refusal
to Fire fauci and even now when when
there was an interview and they're like
why didn't you fire fouchy I can't
remember where it was on might have
mechanisms but he was just like oh you
know the left gets and people were like
are you kidding is that is that legit
I don't I don't I don't I don't know
what's gonna happen in 2024 but I'll
tell you this Donald Trump was the
Avatar of the Rage of the poppy of
populist moderates in this country and
if there's nowhere to place that rage
it's going to go wild yeah Donald Trump
specifically said eight days ago that
those who don't get the shots those
dying in the hospitals didn't get the
shot those are his exact words so
um and again there's a lot of data
there's a lot of information coming out
whether it's the New York Times Daily
Mail or even this uh latest Robert Koch
Institute report that kind of cite the
opposite of that and there's a lot of
debate surrounding that so again Mass
generalization you're going to die if
you don't get this well there's a lot of
information that's up for debate about
that what Trump said was uh oh no the
vaccine works the ones that get very
sick and go to the hospital are the ones
that don't take the vaccine so he is
definitely implying heavily that you may
end up definitely at least it's within a
paradigm right so it's within a paradigm
that you don't have if you have no if
you're in a paradigm that you have no
control over your health or your
well-being right if you're unhealthy and
you believe that there's just this
standard American diet that you can eat
and that's it that's just life then that
is a solution within that Paradigm other
people you know in the Natural Health
world this is viewed as laughable like
if you start following natural healthy
people that you know are incredibly
vibrant right and you start following
them
um just follow them on Instagram look up
the top 10 Natural Health people that
have incredible Health incredibly
vibrant I mean have you ever heard of
Wim Hof maybe yeah oh yeah it'd be
amazing if you could get them on the
show you know but people like that but
what's funny is I bet that you couldn't
even bring anybody to talk about
anything natural on the show because you
couldn't even broadcast it so I mean
there's so much it will take you down
yeah like I haven't been sick in 10
years so much as a common cold but I'm
not going to get into that you know so
so you've got to understand that like
this is a paradigm that they're in and
this is the problem with not having free
speech is that somebody could be correct
within a paradigm but then there could
be this whole other Paradigm in which
there's another way of seeing it YouTube
doesn't for nuance you know and and the
people who delete videos on social media
are typically not versed in politics and
can't tell the difference between you
know certain like issues a good example
is there was a a post on Instagram it
was a famous Pro lgbtq poem that used
slurs but it was like attacking the slur
and then attacking those who would use
it this this person who posted it got
banned and they were like this is like a
very famous poem from the 70s and
Instagram is like we don't know we don't
care then you get there there was this
one really funny thing happened when a
bunch of white feminists started posting
kill all men on on Facebook and Facebook
started Banning them all and they were
like wait why are you doing this and
it's like Facebook doesn't care they
don't care about what you're intending
to say they don't care about your Nuance
the dude in India who is working on this
on this click farm reading through the
stuff doesn't know anything about
American culture just sees words he was
told to delete and he deletes them
that's how it works exactly and many
times even including corporate media
reports that power is abused people have
been putting their own kind of
perspective their own kind of religious
ideologies when it comes to censoring
information on the internet and that has
been used because a lot of these big
tech companies Outsource it to different
countries and when different countries
have different cultural issues they
Implement those cultural issues
sometimes when it comes to the
censorship but what happened to Dr
Robert Malone is absolutely uh awful he
went on did he go on Rogan today um
according to many sources yes he did go
on Rogan and there's going to be a video
published of that there's a previous
video with of course
um not Robert Malone but there's another
doctor that just uh Joe Rogan
interviewed that McCullough those videos
were also censored on on YouTube uh when
McCullough uploaded it on his own
YouTube channel so you know there's a
famous saying when you tear out a Man's
Tongue you're not proving him a liar
you're only tell in the world that you
fear what he might say and you know what
that comes from um no Game of Thrones
yes I thought Tyrion Lannister yeah
Peter Dinklage who said the reason
people didn't like the show is because
they wanted the the white people to get
married or something like that I don't
know I don't remember right now it was
his character great if the show had good
writing before yeah
a controversial opinion I like the
ending but that's a different topic oh
different topic I did I did I did it's
Unique it's different it's not a Disney
movie excuse me but before we get into
that before we talk about that
um again the censorship is totally out
of control and Glenn Greenwald really
had a great comment about this he says I
have a sigh of relief knowing I'm
ad-libbing here that I'm protected by um
uh College wearing flip-flop people
drinking Starbucks away from scientific
debate keeping us safe from from you
know from any kind of rational
intellectual discourse here he didn't
say it that way but he said something
yeah think about Larry King and the
people he would have on his show people
who are not prominent and people who had
despicable ideas and he would put them
on this major show show all of all the
people of the world watching you know I
was at CNN when he was doing the show
and they would be like these people are
nuts now something weird is happening
you have doctor is Peter McCullough he's
a doctor right Dr Malone and they go on
the biggest podcast in the world I'm
assuming Malone's on the podcast but
they've also been um Milan's also been
on Dark Horse with Brett Weinstein and
they talk about their opinions their
medical opinions and it gets deleted
gets removed from the conversation
there's no opportunity to challenge so
it happens those ideas find the
underground people in the underground
watch it uncritically and believe all
that sometimes they should sometimes
they shouldn't but YouTube seems to be
either either it is they care so much
more about making money so they will
delete anything remotely controversial
creating this hyperpolarization or a
form of it or they like creating the
hyperpolis polarization and there's
something nefarious behind it yeah in
the National Health world the big the
big front the big frustration is that
this could have been a moment to get
people to look at health and vitality so
the Natural Health world you have people
that are not only Mass again I'm kind of
dancing around some things here but it's
like massively of just infused with
Vitality I mean if you've seen the Wim
Hoff videos of him hiking up Mount
Everest in his underwear right there's
these incredible things that you could
be doing so this could have been this
this big moment and it didn't have to be
mutually exclusive it didn't have to be
big Pharma or natural but we could have
just included that in the conversation
you could have the whole country
becoming healthier than ever and
mandating no don't mandate it but I'm
just saying there's that Meme where it's
like
um you know doctors you you can't talk
about recommending exercise proper diet
sunlight Vitamin D even though fauci
himself has brought some of this up for
the most part it's not a part of the
equation in the mainstream there's only
one solution and that solution is
vaccination my response is I mean even
fauci's talked about vitamin D and the
importance of it but then these
politicians and and fauci included want
lockdowns which put people in boxes with
no sunlight they get no vitamin D then
they get sick I don't even know if
natural necessarily even the right word
for the broader picture of just Health
just General Health I think yeah I think
he talked about vitamin D once and you
know the windhof method the windhof has
has literally broken a scientific belief
systems with some of the things he's
been able to pull off uh and as soon as
you know everything happened I remember
just doing the windhof method as soon as
covet hit I went uh got on a farm in
Pennsylvania and I just started doing uh
cold bats and breathing exercises and
it's you know personally I can't tell
you guys what to do but personally I saw
a lot of results from it and again we
should be able to have a discussion
we're not medical doctors we're not
scientists we're not here to tell you
what to do but but you know these
conversations we should be having in an
open platform and we can't even really
do that so this is why it's important to
be this is why censorship is bad and I
think everyone everyone gets this but
I'll just iterate it or reiterate it
when I call a doctor I get coven and the
doctor says it's a virus go to bed and I
was like okay
I ended up talking to Joe Rogan because
I knew he got some kind of treatment and
then he said look man find a better
doctor call somebody and then I called
another a private practice out here and
I talked to a doctor and they said I
want you to take these specific
medications
here's the problem that was a doctor
telling me what to do but Don Lemon says
not to do this so you I mean at what
point do we say oh we're going to file a
lawsuit against these companies for
intervening in proper medical care when
when Joe this is what really pisses me
off Joe Rogan comes out and he says
here's what I got someone calls their
doctor the doctor says I want you to do
this and that person says no doc I won't
because Don Lemon told me not to it's is
there gonna be like a wrongful uh death
suit when when CNN makes fun of Joe
Rogan for taking horse dewormer and it
makes people not want to get medicated
my concern is that people in Africa who
need ivermectin for river blindness will
now think it's some kind of sterile
sterilizing agent because a bunch of
journalists reported that it was it's
insane so we we need to be able to have
conversations that are reasonable and
rational but the these big Tech sensors
ain't letting it happen let me show you
what's going on here we're gonna pull
the start from TMZ we're gonna get into
the danger zone territory on YouTube but
we need to talk about this Aaron Rodgers
NFL teams are recommending my coveted
medical regiment to treat players what
Aaron Rodgers who famously took
Ivermectin a concoction of other drugs
to fight covet says he's 100 sure NFL
teams are recommending his same medical
regimen to players to get over the virus
the Packers Superstar made the claim
Tuesday on the Pat McAfee show insisting
that he knows for a fact teams believe
his method of staving off coronavirus
can work I do know behind the scenes
this is 100 true there are many teams
who are using who are recommending a lot
of the same treatments that I got for
their players as we reported Roger said
after he contracted coronavirus in
November that he used a combination of
drugs similar to Joe Rogan to recover
from the virus quickly I'm gonna tell
you this and we always say it
I don't I don't care for Aaron Rodgers's
medical advice I do find his opinions on
how he was treated interesting now if
I'm going to take action it's not going
to be because Joe Rogan told me to
ingest Something In fact when Joe Rogan
said take it seriously and and try
calling this you know find another
doctor I said I'll I'll I'll take it
seriously because I don't want to end up
in a hospital or something like that and
I found a doctor who said monoclonal
antibodies I said I know that is an eua
authorized treatments the regeneron
treatment I know Trump got it okay let's
do it they gave it to us they also said
they wanted to take us a bunch of other
drugs including Ivermectin to which I
said I don't think I need it because the
monoclonal antibodies in my view worked
within within 12 hours I was feeling
better I was feeling like I was
recovering everything the pain was was
gone it was incredible and I said why
should I take this and they said I your
doctor have prescribed you a series of
medications and you need to take what I
prescribed and I said fine the problem
is when when people in the NFL are
getting that same prescription from
doctors
but regular people are being told not to
not to follow their own doctor's orders
because of YouTube because of CNN
because of Don Lemon we're gonna have
very serious problems in this country
because I will say your doctor should be
the person prescribing this to you and
then you look at what they're talking
about didn't Joe Rogan also say that
Congress got similar treatment something
is wrong when we can't have a
conversation about what this is when
doctors are prescribing it when
high-profile institutions are reportedly
prescribing it but you're banned for
bringing it up yep and they're getting
better and everyone else is told to go
home we haven't even prioritized early
treatment and secretly the NFL so no one
finds out according to Aaron Rodgers is
doing the treatments that the mainstream
media The Establishment the politicians
are telling you not to take it and
they're not and they're not doctors
exactly the problem I have and I've
tweeted about this a lot is that these
people are like oh I drove into a
parking lot and just someone just gave
me a shot and I'm like did your doctor
advise you did you go and talk to a
doctor talk about look allergies maybe
allergies Guillain-Barre syndrome I know
it's incredibly rare but I'm wondering
if what we're getting in the vares
reports could be attributed to people
who aren't getting proper advice from
medical professionals so at the same
time at YouTube and all these other
platforms are like we don't want medical
misinformation I'm like stop fouchy
didn't stop oh but fauci is the
authority so he's allowed to be wrong
and then correct himself later nah this
is a ridiculous game it's an absolutely
ridiculous game my recommendation is to
always talk to a doctor get a second
opinion we're not MediCal experts
neither is YouTube neither is Aaron
Rodgers neither is the NFL but neither
is Don Lemon so when you hear these
things are being prescribed by doctors
we need to be able to have conversations
about what that means I'm just pissed
about this the Viewpoint for health in
in the East for example would be say
that you have a business and you have
payroll right you don't get to the point
where you're in you're in cash flow
deficits you know you don't get to the
point where you're you're behind on
paying your staff you want to have this
big cash Reserve serve where you're
ahead of the game and you have such a
big cash Reserve that if you lose a
little bit of cash it doesn't hurt your
business so the Eastern philosophy of
this of health is that you get so far
ahead in your health that if you take a
little knock it's not going to impact
you the same way that if you're behind
so the Western View is more reactive the
Eastern View is more proactive but even
me I've had a great run of 10 years
without having any problems I'll never
make a video on that no way and you
think people like LeBron James and Tom
Brady who know this you think that
they're not aware of it and they have to
make a decision do I want to speak up
you know LeBron kind of had his little
Spider-Man meme where that's his way of
getting it out I'm just mad about that
yeah yeah Tom's just like oh yeah I did
it I mean
so the point being is like we'd imagine
a system where somebody is famous and
Powerful as LeBron James or Tom Brady
might even feel uncomfortable to give
their actual opinion about these things
somebody like Aaron Rodgers he just kind
of old school he's like well you know
like he doesn't even know what's going
on so he just speaking like old school
he doesn't even know the change in
culture that's happened
um and people like Aaron Rodgers that
are more and more old school there's
gonna be less and less of them as time
goes on unless things change yeah the
establishment treatment for this is the
vaccine we also have to understand that
no not not treatment a preventative yeah
the establishment's answer to all of
this is the vaccine right it's their
bottom line there's vaccine mandates
within the NFL within the NBA which also
should be sparking a lot of questions
like okay they're they're all vaccinated
what's really going on here when they're
still getting sick here and they're
professional athletes in the top of
their health that should be a question
that we should at least be able to kind
of even talk about or conceive I'll say
I want to make sure I say this too look
Aaron Rodgers could be wrong I'm not
going to pretend that just because he
said something is definitive we wouldn't
need to do some some fat checking and
get some confirmation it's very
difficult I would also like to bring up
though um we just broke a record in the
United States for a 24-hour period of of
coveted cases being reported New York
City overwhelming and we've had people
guests on the show from New York tell us
like yeah everybody they know they got
it and it was bad and so I don't know
I'm not a doctor I'm not a scientist
don't work for Pfizer but I do have some
questions about what's happening with
the with the majority of New Yorkers who
are vaccinated but still getting sick
how is that that can't be a breakthrough
case anymore can it could it just be
that the vaccine isn't stopping the
variance at all well again we don't know
a lot of this because a lot of the data
is being hidden away from us the CDC
director just announced after major
corporations asked her to to to stop the
quarantine from 10 days to five days she
just came out on CNN today and said
quote it really had a lot to do with
what we thought people would be able to
tolerate explaining her decision to why
she shortened the quarantine time after
major corporations asked her to do so
that's not science that's not that's not
anything definitive that actually might
help people or not help people what made
you come down to this decision what
we're going to tolerate there's a lot of
implications behind those words I'm so
done with the the the social media
guidelines or whatever because they're
out of date they make no sense they make
no sense at all the the science has
changed so often and so quickly and then
changed again that I don't even know
what the rules are at this point it's
like can we talk about one of the most
famous quarterbacks in the world saying
what the NFL is doing on Joe Rogan no
idea literally no idea so I'm just
waiting for that bandham or any moment
because they're just like someone at
YouTube here I'll tell you what's going
to happen because we've seen to other
people
uh Crowder cites the CDC strike yeah
it's like he was reading the CDC uh who
was it um this there was a CDC article
that was labeled fake news on Facebook
do you guys remember that amazing none
of this it's it's look maybe just the
system is imploding maybe there at some
point when we had all these different
when we had like five different channels
and all the news came from these very
specific sources it was easy to control
the narrative now there's no controlling
it it's just smaller tribes throwing mud
at each other and YouTube is like
they've got a lot of power and so like
we're banning all of this meanwhile the
NFL is doing this it's like I don't even
know I don't even know how you define
what's mainstream anymore is a celebrity
famous no idea no idea I don't think so
I think we fractured such an extreme
degree nothing is making sense yeah what
do you make sense of it like what's your
sense of it Owen how do you make sense
of all this
from your like perspective uh
understanding the social dynamics
anything that thing that I any anything
that I make an argument I you've heard
the idea of a straw man argument okay so
a straw man argument is where you attack
the weakest possible position of that
argument okay and you probably have that
done on you Tim I bet you you've had
that done where somebody takes what you
say we like to steal a man yeah right so
so you know what it feels like to have
somebody completely cut you out of
context make you take jokes that you
said that you you know didn't even mean
um turn you into a cartoon character I
mean look what's happened Alex you
mentioned Al Jones before who I've
learned about from your show and it's
like look at what's been done to him
it's completely insane um and it doesn't
mean he's perfect all the time but look
at how they cut him out of context
they'll cut people out of context so
what I do is I try to do the courtesy of
somebody who I disagree with I try to do
the steel man argument for what they're
doing so if you look at something like
censorship I ask myself okay what is the
steel man argument for that much of a
violation of the First Amendment but but
it's not doing them courtesy it's for
you okay if if you know all everyone
listening if you want to truly win an
argument you must argue against their
strongest position yes it's easy to try
and argue into the weak position but it
also looks makes you look weak like I
don't know if you guys saw that video of
Madison cawthorne punching the tree
you see that one there's there I I think
it's Madison Hawthorne like the left
likes playing it all the time it shows
him punching a tree that's rotted out
and I'm like you guys don't look strong
for making fun of a dude like making fun
of this dude you know what I mean you're
going after possibly the weakest
possible thing has nothing to do with
his political arguments it does not make
it look like they have anything
substantive to say because they're
making fun of making fun of a video of
him punching a tree I'm like what does
that tree have to do with my taxes okay
so so what is the strongest possible
version you know for example with what's
happened in 2020 of the need to censor
so they would say things like
misinformation so what if somebody who's
very very charismatic right human beings
do respond to Charisma we respond to
who's the most certain of themselves
right and then you know they're one of
the big Arguments for censorship is they
say freedom of speech is not freedom of
reach so yes you have your free speech
you do in your basement but you know you
shouldn't have that amp you the big Tech
doesn't owe that to you to amplify that
that's what they would say right so then
imagine a world where big Tech didn't
censor and then all of a sudden some
super charismatic person is like you
know take the pair you just eat a pear
and then everyone's like pair pair pair
pair it's like pair pair pair pair so
it's kind of coming from a mindset that
the average person is is too naive and
dumb not to fall in with somebody who's
very charismatic and so what that tells
me if you value the first amendment is
you've got to start saying to yourself
well why is it that people's like people
are being framed as stupid people are
being framed as naive and what would it
take to get our population to a point
where they are capable of seeing
multiple different arguments they're not
going pair pair pair pair like what does
it take to get to that point what do we
have to change in our education system
to get to that point because the
ultimate answer could never be getting
rid of the First Amendment that's not
the answer right but if the count if the
steel man argument is what about the
pair guy it's going to destroy the world
well if that's the counter argument then
what would be you know our response back
to that you know we need to teach more
critical thinking
um we need to teach people how to have
the ability to look at multiple
different sources of information and to
parse through it and to see what is
accurate there's there's a couple of
really uh good ways to look at this
when covet happens I say okay if I want
to go out to eat there's a risk we got
covet I know how bad it is there's a
risk I'm willing to accept certain risks
to have my freedom and I would never
tell you not to go out to eat because
I'm scared the other side of this are
the people who live in big cities who
are like I'm scared so you shouldn't be
able to go out and get food the the two
different factions are basically are you
willing are you demanding someone else
take action for you or are you when they
take action for yourself and to protect
others you know what I mean yeah it's um
what I'll be on the street so I'm I live
in Hollywood right in Los Angeles and
I'll be on the street and if I don't
have a mask on you'll hear people
shrieking out like put on your mask and
you can almost tell it somebody who's
never had status before and they finally
have the ability like they've always
wished like that day is coming when I'm
gonna get to yell at people and put them
in their place right you could almost
feel it in their nervous system that
they're not used to being able to do
that and they finally get to write up on
you say put that on right now and they
they haven't done the research they
don't have their opinion is not based on
any real critical thinking but they've
just got that big moment you know just
just to make a problem and so on and so
forth and the thing that it did to me
living in La
um was that it alienated me from Los
Angeles in a great way because being
around so many people that don't have
critical thinking and that just kind of
go along with that I found it to be
terrifying and it got to the point that
even with my children I started just
traveling the country and bringing my
kids outside into Montana you know where
there's grizzly bears and teach them how
to manage themselves around wildlife and
teach them critical thinking because I'm
terrified that there's been a breach in
the social contract I just believe that
you know the people who we could
normally look up to and just say Okay
they've got our best interest there's
been a breach in that and so now I've
got to train my children like hey think
for yourself think for yourself think
for yourself be adventurous Don't Be
Afraid don't fall into safetyism and
I've got to train them on that
um and I also think that that when you
start using Collective action for things
that are maybe a little heavy-handed and
overreach what it does is it takes
future situations that we might need
Collective action like in that movie
don't look up we may need Collective
action but if you're going to be the boy
who cries wolf about any little thing
then someday when we need Collective
action we're not going to trust them and
so that's creating just this total
that's that that point is actually made
in the film what what I uh what I really
liked about don't look up is As much as
I felt it was very Lefty perspective is
that they they they didn't
I'll put it this way some of the
arguments they made were Steel Man
arguments so the minor spoiler alert
just want to make sure everybody hears
this before I say this next point it's
not a big plot point but there's a point
in the film where where the president
basically says great like hole in the
ozone you know climate change plagues
nuclear war Terror we've heard it all
before prove it and I was like we're
supposed to be rooting for these
scientists who are just like trust this
this picture we have and I'm like that's
actually not a bad point the idea that
the entire world would react and take
Collective action based on a handful of
people who are trying to assert their
right when when we are a decentralized
power structure it's not so simple yeah
it was a good movie Chris I told you so
but anyway Joe Rogan made a very good
point I tweeted out this video and it's
him pretty much saying you know I worked
on my health almost my entire life I've
taken supplements I worked out I've
taken care of myself and then you have
literally obese people that have never
taken responsibility for themselves have
never taken care of their body who are
telling me that that I need to do a
certain thing for them when they're not
the ones that are taking care of
themselves this is absolutely absurd he
had other uh more kind of French words
for it but but he makes a very good
point because a lot of these people who
are screaming at you that are telling
you what to do are some of the people
who haven't taken their responsibility
who haven't taken that important role in
their life and said okay this is
something that I need to critically
think about this is not something that
is going to going to go away if everyone
does what I say or if everyone wears a
mask it's not it's going to go away once
you start taking care of yourself we
start worrying about the terrain we
start talking about the treatment and
again what would happen here with Aaron
Rodgers we got to support him that's why
I put his jersey behind me there he's
getting attacked by a lot of corporate
media institutions so is Kyrie Irving
he's coming back to the NBA in a very
poetic way
uh but but there's so many of these
individuals they deserve our support
because they're actually speaking out
against these larger truths when a lot
of people are afraid to do so or they're
just screaming uh just nonsense muffled
nonsense behind their masks I have a
question
has there has there been any other time
that you can think of where the the
older Generations sacrificed the young
for their safety we have the story from
timcast.com Teen facing two years in
prison for violating covid rules in
Australia the 19 year old teen was
arrested after visiting a nightclub in
South Australia following a positive
covid-19 test now I want to be real with
everybody kind of a dick move all right
when we all got coveted here we said
everybody if you're not sick work you
know work remotely we don't want you to
get sick and for the people who are sick
when you're better like yo unlimited
sick time just do your work do what you
can hang out play video games have a
good time consider it a vacation I hope
you get better we um I think anyone
eligible for the treatment uh here ended
up getting it some people who are sick
weren't here and didn't get it and then
I said before you come back I want you
to feel better and take a test we'll get
you a test it's a it's a little it's a
it's you know I don't know 20 bucks
we're not going to mandate them forever
we're only asking you to do this because
you are stick right now and if you're
still sick until testing positive yo
just stay home we're not going to stop
paying you we're like do your thing
for this team to know he's sick and be
like I'm gonna go out anyway dick move
but prison for this right it feels like
there are scared older people who are
the most susceptible and I can respect
that they're scared but to
let me stop right now Fukushima when the
reactor went off or broke and melted
down and the radiation's spewing all
over Luke and I actually went there we
actually went and filmed various stories
and many talks about this the elderly
decided they would go into the reactor
to shut to try and stop it and clean it
up knowing it would kill them because
they said we've lived our lives and we
must do this for the young and I'm just
like man think about that these are
people who are like I've lived my life
now I'm going to die to save the Next
Generation
what we have here in Europe and in the
United States is the inversion of that
it's older people who are like I don't
want to get sick tell them to stay in
their cubicles and take away their jobs
and their income and their resources and
give the money to Walmart it's
remarkable that is cultural Decay to a
to a point where I don't I don't see a
surviving
it's um
to me the way that I've perceived this
personally is like
say the right wing is pro-gun and then
you had a Locus infestation and there's
locusts everywhere and then the right
wing is like yeah and then everyone has
to have a gun now you have to have a
gutted you have to have a gun and you
have to have a gun in you everyone needs
a gun shoot the locus right and you're
like you don't really need a gun to
shoot the looks like yes you do you're
not gonna defend us we'll all die if you
don't have a gun to me this is the
ultimate wish list for people who like
to strip rights it just it's like the
perfect situation it doesn't mean that a
lot of things they say aren't accurate I
think a lot of it is accurate but it is
a perfect dream it's it's the perfect
situation it provides the perfect
justification and so here's here's my
favorite part it would the extension of
this this logic would be like if people
that are more self-responsible came
along and they said I've worked to
become someone who doesn't get triggered
and I'm not sensitive I'm unoffendable
because you you can actually work on
that that's a real thing you can I teach
this I do it you can really really work
to be
yeah you could just like I will teach
this will sound crazy but I'll teach
courses where like I'll have all my
students put me in a circle and just
start yelling insults at me and I just
have to sit there and I have to deal
with it and then I'll get them to go to
Circle and then you realize they're like
why do I care about words this doesn't
matter at all you can easily get out of
this you build your confidence if you're
not so much in your ego if you view it
as a joke you don't take it so
personally you can actively work on that
right so what do people who had worked
on that were to say
um you know it's illegal for you to be
offended or let's say somebody who
worked on their health said it's illegal
for you not to be healthy which is kind
of what they did with the drug war and I
don't believe in that or what if
somebody who's worked to become wealthy
said if you let yourself go broke that's
illegal because it's going to cause a
problem for me or what if somebody who's
worked on critical thinking and how to
look at multiple different arguments or
misinformation and learns how to not be
affected by that or influenced by that
and then I said if you're naive there's
a mandate against being naive right so
what they've done is they've ex they've
used that kind of logic
um to create a situation that frankly I
mean you're gonna have most Freedom
oriented people moving into Texas moving
to Florida going to Wyoming right you if
you've ever read the second book in the
Bible Exodus it's beginning to look like
Exodus where people are like I don't
want to be a part of the satanic system
I want to get out of here I'm moving to
where people are free and Tim I think
you are one of the people who first
brought this up or you said there could
be parallel economies I mean things get
pretty crazy if they keep doing this
they're they're already pretty crazy and
I just wanted to point out I would use
my flamethrower on the locus I think
that's more thing to do but sorry Tim
you were saying something no uh yes
parallel economies yeah so you you've
already you've already seen it there was
a news article about Dan bongino that
they were smearing him he's got one of
the biggest podcasts in the world but oh
he's he's uh uh he's an investor in and
he utilizes specific technology
companies and financial companies that
won't ban him and they're mad about it
the the Media Matters guy was like it
used to just be that if there was a
right winger you could just call up your
friends the company and they'd ban them
I'm it's not literally what he said but
you know you get a point he's like now
we can't
okay that's a problem not it's not a
problem that you that the writers found
a new A New Path towards you know being
able to speak and and flourish the
problem is that you abused your
positions and created this fracture
that's the problem we don't want this
country divided we want this country
United but when you have ideologues
cultists
and they're doing this they're abusing
people they're taking away people's
livelihoods like patreon did I'm
surprised people still use patreon
because the risk to your life I'll tell
you this patreon banned two people
without warning taking away all of their
income so several years ago and it led
to an exodus and there are still people
I talked to I'm like like there are
people I know people found in the show
I'm like I'm on patreon I'm like why
they'll they will not give you a warning
before they take your income away get
off patreon
I mean look there there's issues we've
criticized locals but locals is still
better than patreon yeah and this is
what they do also in China if you
violate the law if you jaywalk they
automatically with facial recognition
take a photo of you and deduct money out
of your bank account in Australia
they're also going after people's bank
accounts as in October they collected
5.2 million dollars in fines for coveted
violations They seized people's homes
They seized their bank accounts they
took away their business licenses for
not following decrees so I think even
with the financial system that we have
right now A lot of people are seeing its
weaknesses a lot of people are seeing
how fragile it is and a lot of people
are seeing what kind of a con game it
really is and that parallel kind of
economy is already happening and I think
it's happening with crypto and I think
it's pretty evident with a lot of people
saying I trust this random Boop coin
rather than of course the US dollar and
I think that's becoming more prevalent
by the day because the US dollar is
becoming more of a joke than boob coin
and it's only a matter of time until
these parallel economies are conflicted
with each other and
I want people to understand something
too YouTube it's really fascinating
YouTube has one of the lowest
um I don't know what the right word is
for it's not necessarily CPM but I think
it was TI who posted this
he said here's how many streams of a
song you'll need to get to earn one
dollar on these platforms and on YouTube
it was like
1215 streams to get one dollar on
Napster it was like 53. people need to
understand this there's a lot of people
who are on YouTube We're on YouTube but
we understand and I've understood this
for a long time YouTube is actually a
very low value incentive for podcasts
and for businesses this is why so many
people don't care this is why Joe Rogan
only puts Clips up on on YouTube he's on
Spotify he knows
podcast platforms substantially more
valuable they reach Regular People
YouTube meets uh reaches for the most
part people who are in the weeds who are
very politically Affiliated now YouTube
is extremely valuable I'm not saying
it's not valuable at all I'm just saying
it's one of the least valuable platforms
what YouTube does offer up is free
marketing and they know it so for us
this is why early in the year we were
like we need to make a website we need
to we need to start doing news we need
to stop relying on mainstream news
sources and that's why we're heavily
focused on memberships and not just
YouTube oh my God I think boopcoin is an
actual real coin I'm not here giving you
any Financial advice I literally just
made up two words out of my mind I'm not
here telling you two interesting boob
coin I'm seeing the comments they're
like bootcoin's real bootcoin this is
the I'm like no no no no no no no not
telling you guys what to do here don't
know anything about boob coin I
literally just made it up I need to
learn more about be more financially
responsible please so here's a couple
challenges that I've seen with what
you're talking about here so one of so
one of the challenges that I've seen is
that as soon soon as somebody would
create an alternate platform the type of
people that most people wouldn't want to
be associated with Will initially flock
there so that creates an initial
branding right and then you've got it
and so there's there's this kind of
messed up argument that people don't get
in my view which is this say that I say
to you right now are you pro-crime right
you're gonna answer no I'm not pro-crime
well actually
yeah okay so it looked I'll be
completely honest if you were if you
were in like a it was a political debate
between left and right and a right-wing
person was like are you pro-crime they
would be like what is that supposed to
mean like yeah there would be no
straight answer okay so let's say that
hypothetically you're saying no I'm not
pro-crime so say that I say to you okay
well if you're not pro-crime then what
I'm gonna do is on every single street
corner I'm gonna put somebody there
who's gonna Frisk you every single
Street Corner that you go to there's
gonna be somebody there and you know
they're gonna start you know they're
going to go in who knows what place to
Frisk you right full body cavity yes
full body cavity search and by the way
if you don't want the full body cavity
search you are pro-crime and then you
say I'm not pro crime I I just don't
want the full body cavity search and
they say what are you going to say to
that person who had a crime conflicted
against them because you would not allow
the full body cavity it's you not
wanting to have your cavity search on
each Corner worth it for what happened
to Little Jimmy over here what are you
gonna say to Little Jimmy who was
affected if they would have a full body
kept do you support antifa no so you're
so you're pro-fascist that's literally
what they do and you're like no yeah but
antifa literally killed people but so
they're rioting so the media works that
works on Optics it works well actually
individuals yeah so if you're so if
you're trying to be Pro full body cavity
search in every single corner all that
you need to do is find five or ten
really really horrific crimes and say
look what happened a little Jimmy and
little Jimmy's like I just want the
cavity Surge and it's like do you care
about them Jimmy right and they can keep
doing that again and again but it
doesn't mean that you're a pro crime the
the the Cure is worse than we got it we
got it we got man we need to get I was
talking to Sheamus from frame tunes
about like comedy writing and doing some
some bits and that would be a really
great bit where it's like an infomercial
like last year little Jimmy was attacked
on the street because there were no body
cavities
just like really extreme Security State
stuff and then you get like a crying kid
and it plays like Sarah Mclaughlin or
whatever so so if you're a business
um and this is one I think one of the
challenge challenges with you know the
typical American individualism right
where in America we say you know you
kind of handle your own I mean what
we're you know back in the day we would
have said you handle your thing I'll
handle my thing so what you have is that
you have on one side you have
collectivism on the other side you have
individualism right so if you're running
a business and then you see another if
you you see that another business was
impacted by this whole little Jimmy
phenomenon you could say hey that's BS I
don't support that this guy is not pro
crime he just he just doesn't want body
cavity searches but if you're running
your business you just kind of keep your
head down and you don't say anything so
in collectivism they'll all stick up for
each other but in individualism there's
less of that so as a result they will
stick up for each other very very
quickly even individuals won't even when
um depending on your Source it's like 26
to 36 dead in the George Floyd riots
they will unabashedly unashamed they
will bail these people out they have uh
their allies in positions of power will
support it on without question and then
you look at the Republicans the
Republicans are like one of our members
of Congress had a naughty word so we've
stripped them of all committee and
booted him from the party and then Ilan
Omar is like I'm just going to keep
talking and the Democrats are like we
literally will do nothing we will
literally do nothing and then the funny
thing is because these people don't read
the news the Democrats just claim it's
actually the Republicans doing it and
they believe it there you go antifa can
go around smashing Windows beating
minorities screaming racial slurs in
Portland which I've personally witnessed
and has been reported numerous times and
the left will defend them tooth and nail
they literally have people getting on
their knees for them in support there's
a lot there's a lot of other psychology
I suppose you were talking about uh oh
and uh that got my attention let me let
me play the video let me it's an old
video I've posted before I've posted it
again the more followers I get the more
I want to keep playing this video here
you go is there is there audio for this
there's some anti-blackness or violence
I will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
is
let me explain for those that are not
watching and can only hear it's all
white thousands thousands of people so
sitting down with their hands in the air
as the the preacher of of social justice
makes a statement and everyone just like
drones I will use my voice this is a
cult now if you want to complain about
Trump supporters all act worshiping the
you know Trump in the ground he walks on
yes but that's the exception not the
rule that is few and far between there
are people who are like that but that's
not the majority of people who are
libertarian moderate or even voted for
Trump a lot of people who voted for
Trump don't like the guy but they hate
The Establishment and they don't want to
be in your cult
so what happens when you don't feel safe
within yourself is that your mind will
not allow you to think Beyond which
opinions allow you to feel more safe so
you know for example like one of the
reasons why things like Christianity or
religion are actually very powerful is
that if you believe that you have a life
beyond the body that allows you to open
your mind to a range of different
thoughts because you're not because
you're not as afraid of getting killed
you feel like there's something Beyond
this right but even just basic level
confidence allows you to think beyond
what you're just supposed to pipe back
so this concept of say some people call
it virtue signaling is this idea that
you know for some people if they don't
feel safe their mind is not scanning
saying is this accurate can I find
statistics on this can I even question
those statistics can I look at multiple
sources their mind is going to what will
get me props when I say this and so I
think to to improve this problem of
people that will say just do whatever
gets them props in the crowd you can
remember back to being back in grade
school some of the trends that were
popular and how the kids would just try
to jump into I'm cool now right is this
cool is that cool and kids would even
beat up other friends like because they
weren't popular anymore things like that
and the cool thing about being an adult
was when you finally get to get away
from that you're like I don't have to be
cool in high school anymore I could just
say what I really think but now Society
is evolving to where it's bringing it
back to that where you have to be hyper
aware of what of what the hive mind is
thinking and if you say something
outside of that it can cost you your
career it can cost you your life I mean
it's totally crazy so I think that I I
had I had a moment like this in Berkeley
during the riots in like 2018 where I
have I had a GoPro and a gimbal so I'm
walking around with this you know little
thing I'm filming what's going on
there's police and I'm talking to
someone when all of a sudden this woman
starts talking to me so it's arguing not
like a fierce argument but she hears
what I'm saying she hears what I'm
talking about and then immediately says
you know starts to interject so I turn
to this woman on a public Street and
she's talking so I ask her questions
there was a woman who was attacked by
antifa and left bloody why well she was
wearing something that was conservative
and so this woman told me well maybe she
shouldn't wear that in an area where she
knows someone might get mad about it and
I said so you think it's her fault for
wearing the wrong clothes and that you
know she should have worn something
different she wouldn't have gotten
attacked and she goes yes and I was like
so you think it was the victim's fault
she's like yeah and then I was like okay
well thank you for your time then after
about a minute she runs back over me she
goes no no don't use any of that don't
use anything and I was like you walked
up to me and started talking and she's
like you're not allowed to use that
footage
I feel the reason she did that was
because she had real opinions real
opinions that a lot of people have like
yo if you stuff your wallet if you go to
an ATM and pull out a thousand bucks and
then walk in a dark alley whistling
about how you got money and you get
robbed people are gonna be like why were
you doing that well it's it's a bummer
you got robbed the burglars the robbers
are the criminals but that was kind of
dumb regular people would say that but
the modern left is like don't blame the
victim when it happened well this woman
genuinely felt there is some
responsibility to be safe and to
understand what you're getting yourself
into but when she realized it went
against the mob and the cult then she
was like delete it don't use it I
blurred her face because I don't think
she matters as a public figure I put the
video up I blurred her face because I
thought what the person was saying and
and the ideology of the person was more
important and I don't want to cause any
conflict for the individual but people
needed to hear all of that including her
her attempts to recant and say no no no
I I don't I don't like that they're
scared of the mob they're scared of
their own political ideology yeah well
they're just really quickly this concept
Owen that you said of the hive mind is
also a very important one that I think
we should expand on so people understand
what's going on because I kind of see
this hive mind being controlled by the
algorithms by big Tech monopolies by
intelligence agencies and and a lot of
powerful people that are able to
influence what we see online and
therefore change our perceptions of what
the world is and what is acceptable and
not acceptable how would you define the
hive mind and how do you think it plays
into all of this okay so well I want to
lead into that by saying that when I see
this clip up here part of me like part
of it I think is beautiful these are
people that are trying to make the world
better they could be watching TV there's
a million things they could be doing and
they're there believing they're making
the world better and I think there is
aspects of what they're saying of what
they're doing that makes the world
better I'm sure if we were to meet any
of these individuals and brought them
here we'd want to be their friend or
that we'd probably have a lot of love
for them right there's they're trying to
do something better I think what turns
people off that are critical thinkers is
that there's a sort of an energy to it
of I'm not thinking
I am repeating back what I'm told so
there's something there's a great book
that you can read that would probably
offer a lot of clarification to anybody
learning about this called the winner
effect and this idea of oh you can also
look up uh Robert sapolski he talks
about uh you know serotonin and immune
system and dopamine in baboons based on
hierarchy and so what happens that in a
baboon tribe Robert sapolski he studied
this he's an incredible scientist and in
the book The Winner effect it talks
about it too is that when you feel like
you're winning your dopamine goes up
your serotonin goes up according to
Robert sapolsky again I'm not a
scientist but what I how I had
understood him he said even your immune
system goes up and so and they show this
whole documentary about it's really
really cool you got to look it up it's
totally insane so maybe you've had a
moment in your life where you're around
you know friends and you're at a party
where everybody likes you and you feel
safe and you feel well received maybe
you got a new shirt on you feel good and
your whole body feels good your mind's
working a little better and you can talk
and talk it's a beautiful feeling to
have right well for most of us the way
that we earn that in a more
individualistic Society is we try to add
more value to society to do better and
to raise in the hierarchy by offering
more and doing better right but if
somebody feels alienated from that
reality and that they can't make it
they've lost their buy-in that they can
make it in that reality then you can
begin to see a different pocket now
particularly with the internet which
internet is amazing both for critical
thinking if you can get off platform and
and look at other sources but it's also
very very good for collectivism right
it's like it's the perfect tool for
collectivism and so what starts to
happen is that if you get this
Collective group that says you can gain
status by having more grievance you can
gain status by feeling more victimized
you can gain status
um by repeating back the mantras of the
group they're getting dopamine from that
and more and more likes and more
engagement and better play in the
algorithm if you do play along these
certain rules which is also critically
important because that dopamine hit is
linked exactly to how many uh reactions
they get and what type of reactions they
get and a lot of that is manipulated
sorry go ahead it's also funny to think
that you know if you're driving down the
street in LA and you're like put on your
mask you know you do that they're
getting a hit of dopamine from that now
what do we know about dopamine well
people who do certain things like that
they get I don't know what we're doing
here on YouTube
that kind of stuff right they um they
wind up uh one thing that they joke
about with people who deal with with
addiction to that is like it's kind of
like Ruffles bet you can't eat just one
they say like there's never like a half
empty bag of that like they'll keep
pumping it till the bag is gone and so
if you're somebody who's never had
dopamine you've never had that winter
effect maybe maybe you feel like your
brain is shut down and then all of a
sudden they tell you you could be a hero
by screaming out your car and by
repeating back the mantras and by saying
all the bad things that happen and
you're like ah I've never felt this way
it feels so right that's why speaking
out is so important shaming people it it
look you need to
mock them
belittle them this this woman on the
plane who spit in the old guy's mouth
because he wasn't wearing a mask dude
was eating he was eating and drinking
she's like put on your mask and she took
her mask down everybody laughing at that
lady and making fun of her that's look
there's there's a limit but the news
about her I'm sure will discourage
people from being that Karen as they
described her okay so having a
disincentive is powerful but again like
what I have found with people is that if
you really give them a dissent super
powerful but if you give people a chance
and you get to know them and you learn
their story you'll no longer see them as
like you know a Karen you'll see them as
a human being who's maybe suffering okay
I've just seen this and so my thing is
like due to the culture war and Tim you
were one of the first people who put it
in my mind that like we could be heading
towards a Civil War and I was like whoa
and parallel economies and
I agree with you on that
um I think at this point we've got to
start looking back to people like
Stephen Covey who says things like seek
first to understand then to be
understood so the story that he tells is
that he's on a subway that's brilliant
yeah and he says um there's these kids
that are screaming on the subway and
he's like look could you tell your kids
to quiet down and she looks at him and
says you know their dad died a month ago
and uh this was the first time I've seen
them happy so I agree with you that they
should have been quieter but I just
didn't want to stop them and the thing
is that I grew up actually uh kind of
like what you call having awesome
Burgers lightly autistic and I grew up
probably as the kind of person to be
honest if it wasn't for the intervention
of self-development I would have been
sitting there in that group like I
promise and I would have been getting
dopamine like yeah like I would have
used my white voice to Aid my at my sure
you know black allies yeah and and I
want to help all people in general
anyway but the point is it's it the
issue there is not that they want to
help helping is amazing it's that you
can feel intuitively like just as a
general Vibe you can feel that they're
in a hive mind right where it would feel
different if you could see that people
were saying it really because they
believe it not just trying to get a
dopamine hit the people could be saying
the exact
judgment it would feel different we need
to make a a film maybe we'll do a short
film and and I always say stuff like
this like as if we're going to do it but
you know where it's people choosing to
become zombies you know in most zombie
movies they're like oh no I'm becoming I
don't want to be a zombie run it's got
to be a lot of people being like why are
you going out there on purpose like
don't you want to join in everyone like
this is cool I don't have nothing no no
it's like this like there's a horde of
zombies in the street just like mauling
and eating people and then someone's
like whoa what's going on out there and
there's smart people being like dude
those are zombies they're killing and
eating people there's a bunch of people
they're like cheering and stuff I want
to be a part of that and you're like no
don't and they go outside they're like
yeah and they get bit they're like all
right and then they're like yes
free food no responsibilities ever
actually what's really interesting is
about the movie don't look up is that
whenever we get these films about like
you know like Deep Impact or Armageddon
or what was the one where they go into
the core the core oh yeah it's always
like or 2012 or the day after tomorrow
they're like I've got a serious you know
problem the Earth is in trouble and then
all the military leaders are like what
can we do about this and they're like we
must bring together a mission and then
don't look up they're like we have a
serious problem and then the president's
just like and and this is you know
spoilers you've been warned the
president's like okay
midterms is in three weeks so if we sit
on this now that's a little extreme but
I like the contrast this idea that it's
going to be like the movies it's just
not true if they're if they're we are
watching right now people in a cult
holding their hands up chanting their
mantras and they think the they think
they would be the people rejecting
Hitler they think they'd be the people
resisting slavery yo you're Marching In
lockstep without thinking for two
seconds you would be right along with
all of the despots and all of the
Mindless hordes that have committed all
the atrocities throughout history but
Tim Tim it's easier just to follow
orders you know yeah like they went PD
going a five-year-old and being like
papers please and the kid goes I'm five
and they're like out yeah absolutely
disgusting but but oh and I wanted to
kind of go to you here you work with
people one-on-one how do you wake people
up what's what can we do to to help
alleviate from your perspective from
from how you break people out of Trance
what lessons could we learn from you in
the digital kind of World okay so well
I'm going to talk about that but I also
want to talk about why I think
systemically this has become such a
problem okay so when you have
collectivism there's an incentive to
look out for the Collective Now in
individualism
imagine that right now you say Okay so
the people that are likely to wind up in
a cult are people who maybe don't know
how to manage their health perhaps don't
know how to manage their money perhaps
get offended very easily uh perhaps
struggle with critical thinking perhaps
struggle with dopamine so you want to
have a reality where people are all
coming up so the way that I deal with
this is that I try to teach people how
to have their come up I do this in a
major way and to be honest a big part of
what I do is like I I kind of give
people a hard time about areas that
they're struggling and then I try to
help them to elevate past that and help
them to find a new safe Zone where
they're doing better okay now what I've
even seen is that if there's a video
that I put out where I'm really breaking
somebody down and giving them critical
feedback people will actually pull this
up and be like why are you saying that
to them how could you say that I'm like
do you want to see the results six
months later when they're financially
successful have a better social life and
credible significant other they're
completely happy like do you want to
look at that or you just want to look at
me actually trying to give somebody a
bit of tough love and things that would
have been like what I'm doing would have
been a joke by 50 or you know standards
50 years ago go
um but that's where we've gotten to so
the challenge that I see as an
individualism is that we all compete
against each other right we're not
trying to have communism we're trying to
have competition so me and you are not
in competition but let's just say that
we were and then I said hey because I'm
worried that you might not step up Luke
I'm going to teach you how to compete
with me better that's the the inherent
flaw in the individualistic system so in
my mind if people don't want to lose
Freedom what I think and this is just me
tabling it doesn't mean I'm right just a
opinion I have I think what's going to
have to happen is that if people don't
want to live in communism they're gonna
you know the different business owners
and people that are accountable are
gonna say you know what we tried giving
all our tax money or not all of us
exaggeration but you know a lot feels
that way but you know we gave our tax
money for public education it wasn't
enough people are still not managing
their health they're not managing their
their money they're not managing
critical thinking uh they're they're in
a psychologically neurotic head space
they're dealing with a lot of neurosis
it's not working maybe what has to
happen is every business owner and again
I wouldn't like force it or anything but
maybe step up and give another couple
percent of their money and say we're
gonna make an organization that teaches
people for free how not to be
susceptible to something like this
because as long as people are walking
around suffering and scared and broke
there will continue you've seen the Yuri
besman off contract oh yeah it's like
they will be an easy Mark for people who
want to control them and then what you
get into is this Dom sub relationship
between the elites and the masses where
they at least come in and say Hey you
know I'll be like Big Bubba in the jail
and you just let me handle everything
and they're like yes just make us safe
just put us in the metaverse put us on
universal basic income tell us to stay
at home give us unemployment they want
to be in prison that's the joke there's
a place that will lock you down for your
own safety there's a place that will
provide you with three Square meals a
day and uh you'll get your Universal you
know your Universal Health Care there
will be no guns you will have your your
boss it's called prison it means it's
not a joke I'm made up but now now that
they're talking about lockdowns now that
they're saying we want Universal Health
Care we want you know guaranteed income
for the basic necessities a place to
live guaranteed housing no guns
and to lock you down for your safety I'm
like yo you guys are just literally
wanting to go to jail aren't you I just
heard from a friend today that lives in
New York and I said I really want
another lockdown to happen I really want
it to happen I'm ready for it I think
that'd be good for me let's just put
anybody
what was there did you ask them why like
was there justification for this I I
know where their head space is like
where do you think they're coming from
well I think it's a place of fear and I
also think it's a place of you know well
fear and safety they're they're afraid
of what might happen to them and they
also I don't know I mean I I don't want
to disparage this person but I I think
that they probably well I think they're
a little bit lazy and I think they would
be more comfortable at home and be and I
think that they would feel like they've
been given the right to stay home you
know and they can just use that as an
excuse It's just like oh I don't have to
go anywhere and this is great I love
where I am you know so this is where if
you were to bring that person on here
and talk to them and have a conversation
and again seek first to understand then
to be understood and creating
conversations where people come together
because the thing is is while we're
sitting here do it
um because you've struggled I've heard
that you've struggled to get people from
a different point of view to come here I
I have privately messaged people and
then they ignore it so then I publicly
and politely will respond to one of
their tweets and then all of their fans
go do it oh man it's gonna be so great
you're gonna wipe the floor with them
and then these progressives go I'm told
totally doing it I'm there name the time
and date and I say I'll have our booking
a producer cover you first class we'll
fly you out we'll get everything taken
care of it'll be on this date or this
date pick your date and they'll go done
we're there then they DM me being like
lol idiot I'm not coming on your show
wow and then they'll go to all their
fans and be like dude wouldn't have me
on this show wow yeah it is a grift we
we well like they it's it's a
manipulation you know it's a show too
that is perceived as a debate like
wouldn't it be powerful to get together
and to really try to understand each
other because hash things out okay so
the most powerful idea and self-help in
my view is this idea of the question is
called what else so for example you
could be watching the Kardashian or you
could be making a million dollars you
know you could be sitting there having
like pining over someone from five years
ago or you go out to a bar club and get
good socially and meet 50 new people
right it's just what else what else what
else what else and so to me the idea of
even a lot of things in pop culture
um even in things with people arguing
it's almost to me personally just the
way I take it is similar to a drug
addiction what do drugs do functionally
they get it to where you're not doing
all the awesome things that would make
your life better so the problem is if in
our country we're sitting here and we've
got around you know 300-ish million
people right and then you've got China
where uh I think it was President XI he
said to Joe Biden we're gonna own you in
15 years and they're not sitting there
having you know as much tribal argument
although I'm sure there's some but if
we're sitting here arguing with each
other and we care about Freedom as a way
of life what's going to happen if we
just said you're arguing and arguing
with each other we've got to get back on
the same page and say rather than
wasting our time on this how do we all
win together sure sure let me let me ask
a question um how do we get on the same
page with China
that out of my paper I just really don't
know there's no difference look I
understand like the the Maxwell case the
Epstein case might unify American
populists but when you have people who
we've invited on the show who have been
on the show and um I I don't want to
rehash you know call people's names but
the people who watch the show know I'm
talking about and I say I agree with you
I think these things are also problems
and instead of saying I'm glad we agree
let's work to solve it they say you're
an idiot you're a liar and they laugh in
my face and then they smack the
microphone wow yeah so so I don't know
how you actually solve a problem when
you have an Eclectic group of people
from moderate to conservative who are
all like we're going to work together
and then you get these left
personalities who are like you're in the
cult or you're getting out of my face
well I think so my theory behind why
people that are in collectivism tend to
do this is that it's the idea that if we
all dim our light a little bit then
everybody can kind of win but at a lower
level well then if anybody starts doing
better socially or financial whatever
it's ruining the pie so that system can
only work if everyone dims their life
together so imagine being on a rowboat
okay and we're stuck at it see we've got
to make it to to the shore and there's
eight of us right and there's just
enough food that if we each take the
exact same amount and if we each row
really hard we'll eventually make it
back to Shore and we can live well if
somebody then says hey I'm just gonna
start pigging out on the food and not
Row the other seven of us might say we
gotta Purge you you're out of here bro
it's not that we want to do this but we
got to do it so we can survive now
that's for survival but in a more in a
communist system that's just kind of
like the way that I interpret it perhaps
I'm wrong on this but the way that I
interpret it is that people are saying
no you can't rise too high because
everybody needs to be at this level then
we have the elites up there and it's
funny because in communism we tend to
think of that as
um it's not good for uh business owners
right but what they don't realize no
it's not good for middle class and it's
not good for kind of upper class but the
elites do amazing in communism is my
understanding of it and then the people
at the lowest level maybe can work
perhaps a bit less although ironically
they'll say Millennials that watch Tick
Tock that won't communism will be put in
a sewing Factory for 18 hours a day
Tick Tock maybe some future version but
you just get it's it's one of those
things where it seems like purging just
seems to be a common theme in a lot of
Communism or you know people in that
kind of mindset because for the whole
like yes yes that kind of thing to work
you need everybody to be on the same
page so there's this purging so the
problem is the dopamine structure in the
brain at that point is getting a
negative reward like do you ever just
watch somebody like maybe Brian Stelzer
and you just feel physically ill I don't
know if you've ever had that that issue
like something like and I'll sit there
watching him and I'm like I'm really
trying like I think I like I really I'm
like I'm trying I'm listening I'm trying
I'm giving you the benefit I'm just like
I'm really listening well I think that
somebody like Brian Stelzer probably
looks at somebody like a Tucker Carlson
or Alex Jones and he feels that way and
he doesn't know why he's just like why
do I feel so angry I think with Jones
he's so unstifled and Unapologetic my
theories they're not even listening to
what he's saying it just makes them
angry that he's not filtering just the
mere act that he's not walking on
eggshells and expressing himself without
a filter is just enraging because they
have the filter and they're like they he
doesn't have the filter he needs the
filter and it's like a mask yeah just
like the mass policy that's right he
doesn't have a mask I have to wear a
mask why doesn't he have to wear a mask
how about we go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast if you want to support our
journalists who do Fierce and
independent work like our good friend
Chris Carr who's been sitting here the
whole time executive editors you guys as
members are helping make all of this
possible now
um I need to address a bit of the this
oh man the the the controversy oh my we
have the soup Super Chat from Wi-Fi 117
as meme worthy as your drunk guest was
last night she seems pretty based I hope
things all right between y'all great I
thought we had a blast last night she's
awesome
and she was very authentic but there
were a lot of super chats that were
concerned about the um
perhaps the amount of alcohol she had
imbibed and I think Amanda's great I
thought she was I thought it was a fun
show I I get it there were people in the
chat saying the conversations weren't
happening there's a mix between some
people saying it was our best show ever
the most entertaining and others saying
they couldn't even listen so look
um I don't I don't want anybody feel bad
about anything you know I think a man is
fantastic we'd love to have her back and
people saying it was meme worthy but
she's super cool we're all friends
um she left everything was great I don't
know I didn't you know well there were a
few people that suggested that I
overport her drinks because I'm the
bartender on the premises and I've been
in the blog he wasn't here that I do
exactly I just want to set the record
straight I was not here that night I did
not pour anything for Amanda but she is
awesome and I admire her greatly yeah we
post Clips on Instagram too and I was
just like every every comment on every
platform from the show was all just like
yo and I was like I don't want to be
mean we we had a bunch of super chats
and a lot of them were like perturbed to
say it mildly and I'm just like oh you
know I don't want to be mean to people
if it's like it was it was not
mean-spirited you know yeah we're not
trying to control the conversation here
we give people free will to express
themselves however they want and you
know
what it's whatever it was entertaining I
thought all right that being said let's
read some more we got what is this
monkey boy King he says Elaine Maxwell
has a job at CNN now yes
article that was absolutely hilarious
and you know with the way CNN's been
hiring lately there's there's a room to
believe that that that article was so
good that when I did my normal news bit
like I did a segment on my timcast news
channel and I was like a second producer
has been arrested I I actually had to
include a satirical article because the
joke about Max while working at CN was
just it was too good standing ovation
absolutely
nailed it all right Kevin Brady says I
went to go get monoclonals today in
Washington state they are no longer
giving them out at all removed before
Christmas doctor didn't understand why
upset yeah I have a number of friends
who are sick who are trying to get them
that are saying that that they just
can't especially I have a friend in New
York I have another friend in New Jersey
and they're and they're having doctors
tell them yeah this is all because of
the governor's fault the president's
fault and you know it's it's absolutely
crazy what's happening here to to have
something that has helped us personally
be denied to people are not there and
it's just almost every step of the way
here we have to be questioning what the
government is doing here because they're
results of their actions are horrible it
gives a lot of credence to some of the
most cynical opinions about what's
happening like these really really
cynical opinions when you see things
like that happening you're like is that
true and it's sad that it's got to that
yeah yeah well you saw the Attorney
General in Florida just came out and
said that they're actively because he
said that he's effectively treated a
hundred thousand people in Florida with
monoclonal antibodies and he said the
bite Administration is actively
preventing us from giving it to people
that need it absolutely that's insane
I've heard from some doctors that
they're just across the board they're
being pulled out and the claim I was
actually told this by a doctor is that
it doesn't work and I was like but I got
it and it worked and it's eua also I
don't understand what it what what
Trump got it
okay I guess I don't know man
mind-boggling thank you for that Super
Chat by the way great point and an
important issue to talk about Nick
beardian says oh and I followed you for
over a decade your work has been a true
inspiration to me my friends and many
people I just want to say thank you for
everything you've done my friend you
gotta lead mother effer nice there you
go yeah you've been in you've been doing
this for a while yeah yeah yeah thank
you that means a lot that's why I do it
devisop says there's widespread
polarization misinformation and
politicization in my country Lithuania I
feel obligated to do something about it
X YouTube tips
I don't know man
speaks you know um you got to read a lot
if you do tell your friends maybe make
some YouTube videos but I'd probably say
get started on rumble or Minds at this
point and YouTube do it all at the same
time give value never give up on
yourself keep trying new things
experiment but understand when you're
playing on big Tech you're playing by
their rules so understand you have a lot
against you the odds are against you but
that doesn't mean you can't succeed that
means when you do succeed it's only
going to be more valuable to you when
you do yeah and the big tip for several
YouTubers being here is the more that
you do public speaking the better you
get at it your first videos you've got
to be okay that it's a bit ridiculous
and that you can laugh at later like
have you ever looked at your oldest
videos on your Channel or you've ever
look at your oldest I had a brooklyny's
accent running away from police officers
that was my first video Yeah the more
that you do it the better you get so
wear those old embarrassing videos with
pride you're going to be so proud of
them someday when you keep doing it
you'll get better and better just like
any sport or playing an instrument yeah
I'd say a cultivate personal
relationships with people in your
community Unity start with your
neighbors people live next door people
live next to those people bring food
offer food offer but that's just just
basic stuff that's a good point Chris
don't rely on the internet to spread
your message yeah the real world also
has an impact yeah especially now all
right Adrian Davis says Tim this is a
celebratory donation I've recently
extracted myself from Denver and am now
back across state in my home county 800
people in my town and I'm so happy enter
Applause here congrats I am Bravo for
for getting away from all that stuff and
find a good place Jessica says just a
reminder that Americans are still stuck
in Afghanistan and according to reports
the state department is trying to
prevent them from leaving never
underestimate Joe Biden's ability to
screw things up um or is it intentional
at this point I think it's fair to argue
that a lot of the stuff the government
is doing that is hurting people and
screwing people over is intentional I
mean how kills can you describe it
especially with how I I just want to
point out in my research for one of my
segments I was doing the other day about
the difference between men and women in
politics women began to disapprove of
the democratic party right around the
fall of Kabul and I was just like I
don't is that is that a strong issue for
women in the United States like with
holding Kabul in a proper withdrawal and
not a I guess so weakness weakness Joe
Biden looked pathetic and they were
probably alike this is terrible like a
terror attack that killed people there's
a lot of very uh pessimistic and cynical
views of why this might happen including
intentional and the fact that that even
has to be seriously considered when it's
this pathetic is pretty sad that's uh
it's a sad day when you have to actually
take some of those opinions seriously
and I think we probably do yeah man all
right zombie
zombie says Tim Colorado Community and
firefighters need a shout out today
multiple fires destroying communities
yeah uh Lydia you're from Colorado I am
from Colorado and this usually doesn't
happen in the winter I was wondering
about that before the show global
warming no probably not global warming
this may just be a warm winter but yeah
it's just a warm winter no it's the
apocalypse oh you're right okay I'm
sorry Greta tuneberg you know uh look
it's the Apocalypse at least that's what
I was told yeah that's what I was told
too
all right
our scene at Lupine says Whoa Tyler
dirted himself on Tim pool best
Christmas present ever see you at the
winter Summit what is the winter Summit
I've been running live events for uh 20
years now so I spent most of my life I
spent as a public speaker in front of
crowds
um so I've often run 50 events a year
just doing public speaking and uh
it's something I think is really
beautiful I was actually one of the
first people to be out doing seminars
again as soon as I had the chance like
my whole team they're like you're crazy
nobody's gonna come and we actually put
one in Miami and we broadcast it live
about all this live gear down we
broadcast it live because I want to be
the first person uh to be doing seminars
again so it's uh and Tyler Durden was
just my old nickname like it was a
nickname back in the day
all right let's see what's up says Tim
when it comes to batacf care that's a
Biden slur for people who aren't
familiar uh a slurring of speech I mean
I recommend you watch the White House
YouTube videos of Biden addressing coven
where they have what he's supposed to
say but it's not what he's actually
saying hilariously sad they translate
for this man when he mothers and then
the media just writes whatever or I bet
they have the transcript that would
actually be real you know what maybe if
we want to know what true and on a shop
of pressure really was we only got we
started look at the transcript because
whatever it is they wrote for the
prompter it's got to exist somewhere
right I'm sure
well unfortunately I don't know um
I don't know exactly if they're gonna
put anything like that out but no way
all right John Bell says was Luke
speaking literally about the Epstein
crew killing children when he said
sacrificing them
uh well you know the term sacrifice
could be interpreted in many different
ways but there's a reason why Epstein
was flying a 727 the CIA airplane that
allows people to throw people out of it
mid-flight there's a lot of accusations
that a lot of children did go missing as
far as like Smoking Gun evidence there's
not a lot of that but there are a lot of
you know circumstances so when we're
talking about sacrificing when you
commit those horrible actions against
children you're you're sacrificing their
innocence you're sacrificing their their
childhood but I also do believe that
there was a lot of children involved
here a lot more than the media States uh
there's estimates of up to thousands and
this is even according to the people
that worked at the airport uh next to
little St James with their documentation
of how many children were shipped in
there uh the numbers here are egregious
Epstein was even publicly bragging that
John Luke Bernay was able to give them a
thousand children
um you know the numbers here are
staggering 30 years of abuse so who
knows um and I think it goes far beyond
more disturbing than we actually even
know about now and I would say
absolutely all right Kevin e says
Brandon Brown will be driving the number
68 let's go Brandon Camaro for the
NASCAR 2022 season hey what if a Super
PAC just sponsored the guy with the
let's go Brandon Carr that'd be great
you know he's struggling sponsor or
whatever yeah I thought he got sponsored
by the fjb coin yeah that's what I did
yeah yeah I saw that that's a great Mark
there fjb is valued at 300 million right
now wow I saw that I mean fact check
that I saw that headline I don't know
where it came from that's what I saw
that's true yeah I did see something
that's amazing if that's true yeah
that'd be awesome that's better than my
bazunka coin yeah
well Tony D says read the gulag
archipelago this is what the average
person can do stop doing things you know
are wrong and stop saying things you
know aren't true solzenitson sped the
collapse of the USSR really yeah wow
Peterson saying too all right muddy says
so many people in the world think that
all the Jeffrey Epstein stuff is a wacky
conspiracy theory that is the goal here
to get the info out there and show those
idiots that it's very real but you've
got to approach it very very
matter-of-factly and you can I love I
love doing things like this in passing
just asserting things as true that are
true but you don't try to convince
someone of so instead of saying did you
know that Epstein did this and and and
Maxwell did this and then they're like
is that true you say something like
you're having a political conversation
be like look well I mean like with the
Epstein stuff which was proven true when
you have somebody that level of power
you just say in passing and let it just
be part of the conversation a normal
part of the conversation don't don't
even let it be something that they're
going to argue with you about you know
just like at the Bohemian Grove when
they do mock child sacrifices to to
molec you know this is the time of the
year that a lot of people appreciate and
usually use for summer excursions and
nature walks
I often like to challenge things when
people say stuff I it's outrageous is
that but I would like to I would like to
throw back to when Luke mentioned Bill
Gates having birth control microchips
and then I Google it in bloomberg.com
it's like a contraceptive microchips
birth control and I was like well look
you didn't make that one up yeah
look up molec look up oh my gosh
all right Justin Chavez says great idea
for a change in the Senate and houses
pay a proposal to set their salaries to
the U.S median household income when the
median income increases so do their
salaries this would force them to
implement policies that help the middle
class or to help policies that will give
them Kickbacks after they leave office
this is the problem it's very difficult
to solve Andrew Yang was like let's give
everyone let's give every one of these
politicians a million dollars that way
they won't be influenced by the
lobbyists and it's like that won't
matter either man there's no upper limit
for these people
it's like you get a million dollar
salary and they go awesome well I'll be
here for two years and then get a
million dollar salary after I leave
because a lobbyist made a promise to me
I don't I don't see there being um
I don't see there being a good solution
man to be completely honest
Paul Anthony says love your show Tim and
friends can we all please stop watching
and reacting to leftist news we are all
just feeding into the BS that they
spread Happy New Year's everyone wishing
you all the best well let me say I'm
going to say a couple things first you
are correct
the problem though is if we ignore the
crazy things that crazy people do
they'll keep doing it and it'll keep
happening right it'll keep getting worse
the other thing is the right moderates
post-liberal whatever faction needs to
get a hold of the news cycle
there there was this Vox article it was
hilarious where they were like Fox News
is controlling the narrative because it
left only ever responds and I'm like
well that's that's ridiculous the news
cycle is almost exclusively set by the
May by the mainstream establishment left
and don't take my word for it axios put
out a story about all of the major news
cycle stories of the year they do it
every year and it is not set by
conservatives it's debated by
conservatives but too often
conservatives moderates Libertarians are
responding to the establishment left
instead of setting the tone imagine if
every single person on the right was
like we're going to talk about this
today the left would be either ex
excluded from the conversation or forced
to to to to engage and a good example of
how this could manifest is if at the
peak of his presidency Trump joined gab
or or mines and started posting there it
would have forced the mainstream media
to join these platforms and it would
have taken power away but Trump oh his
advisor said don't do it
so that was an opportunity that was lost
yes the idea of punching versus counter
punching or being proactive versus
reactive
all right Mike Sullivan says great after
show last night it was fun wasn't it it
was very Trump has been pro-vax but
anti-mandate I'm fine with that
absolutely it's like you I don't care
what your opinions are just leave me
alone and that's why I was saying about
Ron Paul why why I think Ron Paul's
fantastic because he can come out and
say whatever he wants but he always caps
it off with and I'm Gonna Leave You
Alone to do your thing and I'm like
that's pretty good correct you know like
keep me out of it you can have all like
if most of his political ideology
results in letting people live their
lives then well then we we're good right
I agree with that completely but the
fact is politically I think that he's
leaking supporters well not not only
that he's he's talking about non-science
issues saying that only the people in
the hospital are dying are the ones that
haven't been vaccinated that's a lie
that's not true yeah not not in Germany
did you see that the study recently yeah
96
95.9 how many people of how many people
this is according to the Robert Koch
Institute their report we could pull up
the report and look at it but again a
lot of things are being debated here we
don't know exactly what's going on but
this is just some of the preliminary
information we got there was a Reuters
article that said the majority of people
with Omicron in New York were fully
vaccinated and that's true but it was 43
people so that was the early numbers
preliminary numbers but what are the new
numbers I I think they stopped counting
them I'm trying I'm not I'm not saying
it to tell anybody they're right or
wrong I'm just saying make sure you
understand the full context of what the
report says because that small sample
size does matter right exactly exactly
and you wanna you wanna know as much as
possible because what will happen is
you'll come out and say this and you'll
be in a debate with a family member and
then they'll go 43 people that was a
pathetic argument and it's going to be
you know you got you got to know you can
say it's a really small sample size but
let's be real this story exists and then
they can't counter it they're like well
okay you addressed it yeah
Jimmy Freckle says the people that love
Trump and the people that hate Trump are
almost exactly the same person what does
that mean though fervent supporters that
are just by uh on further spectrums away
from each other and they're kind of
radicalized instead of seeing him as
good and bad again yeah Donald Trump as
it's a person I criticized because he
was in a position of power but again I
didn't go crazy like all the other
people that that were acting like total
lunatics going after him for for eating
two scoops of ice cream like it was
ridiculous what was happening out there
everyone in power deserves to be
criticized uh not just worshiped or
adorned or just hysterically uh cried
after all right Bobcat says I just wanna
I just want to know why nobody is
talking about the serial killer loose on
Long Island what we are we did a we
Tales from the inverted World three-part
story three-part story tracking that
sure did um is there a new one
no no it's the same one same one okay I
just want to make sure we didn't miss
some breaking news there's a serial
killer in Long Island over the past was
it three three decades oh yeah yeah
three decades decades
and it's like you'd think that would be
headline news you would think what you
know what's really funny I watched a
zodiac and and I'm watching this and the
movie's so thrilling and then I looked
up the actual story of zodiac and I was
like this is boring yeah the Zodiac
Killer may have been may have been
responsible for like several dozen
murders but there's only I think like
five confirmed ones and it was over the
course of like one year and then they
made a movie about it became a big deal
and I'm like it is it's bad for sure
but there's an actual serial killer on
Long Island over three decades they need
to make a movie about that they don't
care no I guess because zodiac was good
at getting press and the media played
into it never heard of it
yeah that's what's weird Shane did some
really uh awesome investigative
reporting and he uncovered the fact that
it's perhaps not just a serial killer it
could be serial killers right that uh
work together on this wow yeah
interesting awesome work all right let's
see the life of D says the wife lost her
job today because of crooked County's
vaccine mandate she has a medical
exemption and they don't care can I get
a shout out to her she's bummed and hurt
we're officially moving out of Illinois
to a farm in North Carolina yes congrats
I hear you man glad you're moving what's
sir what's her name so we can shout her
out
uh it doesn't say oh well shout out to
your wife shout out shout out for
standing on principles and standing for
what's right and not bowing down and
doing something that was going to hurt
you or be bad for you and you're not
alone yeah we've reported on people uh
that have actually gone through that
same experience and uh you're not alone
man yeah yeah all right base says I'm
chiming in just to say Luke rules and I
miss Ian Ian's on vacation everybody
he'll be back on uh on Monday yes oh
yeah soon soon
Kevin Pilgrim says all I can think about
is how fire that pink flannel is
definitely have to give one yeah
yeah totally yes
all right baby lag says CDC says to
shorten isolation period to five days
where one and a half masks get two to
two to three or four boosters don't step
on a crack or your mom will get covered
and stare at no they're not advising you
to do that
don't stare at the sun don't step on a
crack yeah yeah when um when the CDC
revised their isolation to five days
Mains like establishment left activists
and like the media world all of a sudden
mocking the CDC and I'm like how do you
do that how do you go from saying we
support the science and then when the
CDC is like we've changed our mind
you're lying it's worse than this uh I
trust the CDC the CDC oh yeah how about
that yep so much for for trusting the
science man man
I think it's crazy
celery says Trump being kicked off
Twitter has disconnected him from his
base he doesn't know stuff because he
only reads mainstream media unless it's
on Fox he hasn't seen it this has
created a rift between him and his base
I I don't know if that's true is it you
think Trump was really active on reading
Twitter no well that was kind of like
Candace Owens defense for him when she
did like when she ran cover after the
interview she was just like well she has
very strong beliefs about this issue and
she didn't back him up during the
interview and she's kind of making
excuses for Trump's words and saying oh
he's just old and he only watches the
corporate media and if that's the case
like you're not making a good argument
for him to be president of the United
States yeah yeah all right waffle Sensei
says I've always agreed Luke the ending
to Game of Thrones was good the plot was
good but they crammed three seasons
worth of content into one and called it
an ending you're absolutely right I I
there's like there's like I think a
thousand comments being like we have to
Dethrone Luke Luke's over cancel Luke
for that comment yes I agree they did
rush it but but but I was very satisfied
that I didn't get a Disney World cookie
cutter ending like all the other movies
that end the same way like they usually
do I didn't want to be do something that
was expected I wanted something out of
the ordinary something weird something
different and I appreciated that their
effort towards saying you know what
we're not going to do what everyone else
does we might piss a bunch of people off
but we're gonna change things up a
little bit here and we're gonna make you
think about some other issues and
explore your imagination here and I like
that and I appreciate it so you have in
this show the the characters are in you
know the North or whatever with the
white walkers and they're surrounded
they're like oh no and then they what do
they send a raven or something I don't
know a message and and the message gets
all the way to the south of the
continent and then
um the Khaleesi sees it and then flies
all the way to the north of the
continent within what a few hours just
like that and she has dragons there's no
reality here there's just dragons
there's nothing real here okay we're
living in Magic World and fairy tale
land sure it was interesting and I
thought what that that series did
especially you know in the beginning was
awesome you know you know always baffles
me about movies you could add a line of
dialogue to solve a lot of these things
where she could be like there's no way
we'll make it to North in time I just so
happen to have one teleportation scroll
available perfect and then it just
blinks and they're there and you're like
okay guys deus ex machina
all right
let's see
Brian Cox has saw Tick Tock where
homeschooled kid says Montana looks like
Biden sniffing Idaho oh did you guys see
that I have seen it yeah it's no it's
very convincible yeah deeply convincing
scary you cannot see it that's great
okay let's see we get some super chats
here
I can't read this name as why it's w
question mark whatever oh in your video
about 10 years ago about Batman and
crawling up from your lowest point
probably saved my life from the
Heartbreak of life from the Heartbreak
heartbreak I was experiencing wanted to
know the work you do really helped
someone thank you that's cool man that's
great this is big news that's
danzatastic says the charges for the
truck driver sentenced to 110 years in
prison has been reduced to 10 years wow
wow well there you go man wow
this is cool uh Angel Valentine says
Owen saved my life his teachings are
mind-blowing one of the ogs of early
YouTube wow thank you very cool there
you go right on Dragon Lady says lib
friend quote Trump should tell his
supporters to get vaxxed they'll do
anything he says me post articles of
trump pushing the Vex him oh I missed
that they must have they must have two
or maybe they're not blindly following
cultists like you believe they are
that's exactly what I've been saying
Trump did a rally and he was like you
know we did the vaccines and you got to
get them and then everyone's like Boo
and then they're like Trump supporters
are an occult and I'm like they're
booing him they're they're they're in a
rally in a stadium booing him that they
can't see they can't see him I think
that was a fair point though that group
think is not exclusive to the left it's
also in the right it's also anywhere
it's in any business it's anywhere the
idea that we can save mental energy by
letting other people do our thinking for
us which can be a good thing in many
ways but also has to be extracted if we
don't want to have chaos
Mr Hunt first name Mike oh uh I'm gonna
tell you a quick story so when we were
at the casino a few weeks ago I was
playing a slot machine and they were
like you know Deborah Jones please meet
your your family in the Eatery or
whatever and and we hear it over the
speaker and I didn't care and then
within five minutes we hear
Mike
last name they didn't say they said the
full name your your friends are waiting
for you in the Eatery and I started
busting out laughing I'm like somebody
actually pulled it off and some lady
walks past me and Allison and she's like
did they just say that and I was like
they did and she goes it was an older
lady goes Bravo whoever pulled that off
all right he says Joe Rogan is not a
beacon of free speech and journalism he
has a secret contract with Spotify he
has removed videos of undesirables Gavin
McGinnis Milo and Stephen Greer sure he
has Alex Jones that's just to keep his
right-wing audience
it's been a while since we talked about
this but there there were several
episodes of the Rogan podcast that were
not transferred over from YouTube to
Spotify I think Carl Benjamin was one of
them yeah I don't know why that was yes
and I do not believe that Joe was was
honest about what happened but I can't
remember to be completely honest I think
he said something like there was a
transcoding error or didn't save now
that that actually happens it's happened
to us there have been several instances
where so when we do the show we're
streaming and recording using what's
called open broadcasting uh obs
there have been certain uh issues we've
had where the the recording crashed and
then I'm like okay well we can just get
it off YouTube right and then when you
go to YouTube to click download it's
grayed out and you can't and then we try
I think we've actually at one point did
a hard screen record of our own show
from YouTube to try and get a version of
it we have to try so we basically turned
on screen grab and then just walked out
of the room for the two hours of the
show Play on YouTube so we could record
it so we could then make clips from it
sometimes that does happen I gotta say
though
um of all of those people of all the
episodes yeah weird right but all the
controversial ones but still they
haven't figured out this error I still
think Joe is extremely important look at
the stuff he's been saying recently the
people he's having he's having on he is
he is pushing and he is speaking out and
I respect it 100 so I'm not going to
pretend that Veritas is Invincible or
Joe Rogan's Invincible or that we're
Invincible there's always something that
people like have to concede upon to try
and you know move forward so sometimes
you have to retreat in battle to try and
win the war that being said
I think maybe maybe it's not always as
perfect I think most of us believe that
he's doing his best and we don't know
what he deals with day to day I believe
he's doing his best so yeah and not only
his best he's doing incredible work
highlighting doctors that are being
censored giving them a voice and having
an actual scientific debate we couldn't
ask Grant anything more he's putting
everything on the line he's putting skin
in the game and we have to give it up to
him he's he's changing the narrative and
I think he destroyed a lot of the bull
crap that that we had to face so Props
to him he's doing absolutely incredible
work and deserves our support all right
digabboom says great after show last
night your future wife is Lucky Luke
Tim stare at Luke please
[Laughter]
the other day for those that didn't see
it in the in the members only segment I
I Luke mentioned how sometimes there
will be like a pause and then he looks
at me and I'm just looking at him so it
looks like I better talk but I was
saying well it's like if I'm talking too
much and happens all the time the guest
finishes all like look to Luke to see if
he wants to add and then Luke's like too
wrapped up in the chat or something and
then he's like oh not being called upon
but I always I always deliver though I'm
always like I'm on it I always got
something to say I have to stop I have
to stop myself I like a lot of times I'm
really happy with the intro to
yesterday's episode yeah that's where I
was like that's it it's the Maxwell
thing take it away Luke and then Luke
just was like he like Luke had
everything written down perfectly ready
to go and he's like yes Epstein this is
the moment we've all been waiting for
Tim how much of your audience is fully
aware of what extreme things Luke has
done does your audience facilities yet
like have they seen like the Hong Kong
videos the Epstein video like do people
realize that who you're talking to and
what you've done oh no no I I love when
we have like a guest here doesn't know
look and I'll be like Luke's been to
Epstein
what are you doing over there yeah but
the first time Luke was like not like
that like I got on a boat after he was
arrested and was doing journalism oh how
much your audience truly understands
your background and his background the
extreme things you guys have done I
don't know I mean look
um to be honest if we talked a lot about
the work Luke has done YouTube might
shut it down I mean I had a I had a lot
of very nice conversations with you know
people like Henry Kissinger Lord Jacob
Rothschild The Rockefellers there's a
there's a really there's a really funny
moment I mean he's put his life in
danger and I'm pretty sure you know too
yeah uh it was me it was Cassandra
Cassandra McDonald now uh but formerly
Fairbanks and Luke and we were at a
protest in New York and we're filming
and then afterwards we're leaving it's
the three of us and uh we all have like
decent followings and then all of a
sudden Luke sees I was at Donald
Rumsfeld and then just like standing
standing there in the street and then I
was like I'm gonna ask him questions and
so there's this video now of like me and
Cassandra standing next to Rumsfeld as
Luke asks him questions and there's
people who are like it's a conspiracy
there's no way all three of them were
there at the same time and rumsfeld's
there and he's answering Luke's
questions oh yeah yeah I set that at one
I set that one up perfectly I'm like
he's like oh hey how's that can you get
her photo and then I took her microphone
I was like what about those missing
trillions at the Pentagon right before
that September event in 2000 and you
know which date I'm talking about here
what did he say I don't he was like wait
what
oh there's nothing about you don't have
to worry I'm like there's there's so
much there's trillions of dollars
missing we should you should answer this
and there's another moment where Luke
you confronted Ben Bernanke oh yeah but
you were inside a secure event with uh
what's his name uh Paul vulgar Paul
volcker walked me in there because he
was lost and I was helping him get
around as I'm helping Paul volcker get
around I'm having a conversation about
him going to Bilderberg right and
there's these these security guards and
they have a VIP section where all the
speakers are going and as I'm talking to
him about attending Bilderberg he I just
walk right into it right with him
talking to him security didn't even stop
us and there's Ben Bernanke I'm like
sorry Paul I'm gonna have to stop in
here for a second I'll be right back
went up to freaking Ben Bernanke and I
was like how does it feel pulling off
the largest transfer of wealth robbing
the people of this world for trillions
of dollars but your secret Banker
bailouts he literally grabbed the
microphone tried to rip it away for me
so he could steal it so no one would
hear the questions and I was like oh you
don't like that it's already recorded
what'd you do at Bilderberg then why
don't you answer that question so but
here's the best thing so on Reddit they
were like there's no way Luke's legit
he's fake how did he get in this event
so we came up with a skit idea my
brother made photoshopped images of Luke
at parties with Ben Bernanke we have it
downstairs on the wall yeah and there's
a picture of Luke and Ben skydiving
together and so then like the skit is
Luke gets a phone call and it says you
know Ben Bernanke he's like Benny what's
up yeah I can come down yeah we'll do
like a fake thing where I pretend to get
you and then Luke pull out a lot of cash
in that can you get more Reserve notes
I'm running low people think you know
crazy stuff all right we'll just read
this one more here we got the life of D
says LOL the wife is Christina and she's
in tears thankful for your support have
a great New Year's timcast team much
deserved yes good work we've got um
we're having a party tomorrow for the
crew and everybody here we've got wegu
beef
everyone's gonna get a little bit it's
very expensive and we're gonna have
Trump champagne we secured we procured a
bottle of trump champagne and it's
apparently hard to get right now
tremendous we went to we went to the
liquor store it's probably up on the
Vlog or whatever because we're like
we're gonna get libations for the event
and we asked if they had Trump champagne
the guys looked very hard to get uh
champagne in general right now so we got
some and we're gonna enjoy ourselves so
we won't be around tomorrow but
everybody who watches the Show
everybody's a member we really do
appreciate your support smash that like
button you can unsubscribe to this
channel go to timcast.com become a
member to support our journalists you
can follow us timcastirl basically
everywhere we put up Clips on Instagram
and Facebook you can follow me at
timcast uh oh and you want to shout out
your socials uh Owen Cook self-help and
that's my that's basically I've been
traveling the whole entire country
recording videos all over the country
outside and then Owen Cook free tour I
do free events all over the country big
free seminars Owen Cook free tours where
you can see those seminars I actually
post them right on I want to thank uh
the people in the comment section that
that said that I redeemed Myself by
bringing Owen I know I usually I usually
a great range
microphone did you hear it I'm not that
guy
oh no no no no no
I'm very happy this worked out so uh
okay so I have my own media organization
it's called we are change I did a full
video on the Maxwell escapades you can
watch it on youtube.com we are change I
did a spicy video on lukeansensor.com
that's where you could support me
because you do I'm here it was fun it
was a great conversation we should have
more of these it's incredible so thank
you so much for all of you guys uh who
participated in it and all the amazing
people who give us our time and
intention it really means a lot that
we're able to spend time with so many
amazing people especially in the comment
section especially here it's it's just
one of the funnest things so thank you
guys for all being a part of it
absolutely uh chriscar 17 on Twitter
shout out to Mark and Pat very cool
thank you guys all for tuning in this is
a great conversation I always love it we
can get a little more cultural because I
appreciate the philosophy and asking
some of the underlying questions about
what's actually going on anyway I hope
you guys all have a great New Year's Eve
I'm really looking forward to it I'm
gonna go see some Christmas lights I
hope and you guys can follow me on
Twitter at Sarah patchlands thanks so
much for hanging out and being here all
year my friends the midterm cycle is
starting to ramp up so you need to
understand that the censorship the
smears the trolling it is going to get
intense anybody who's challenging The
Establishment will be will be run across
the coals they'll be going after you
they'll be going after Russ they will
try to shut down anybody who who is
telling you you know vote in the
primaries vote local so we got to be
ready for this for the censorship that's
going to be big they're going to start
Banning people they're going to find
reasons to do it
this is going to get spicy we don't know
who's going to win yet history and polls
say Republicans but if dirty games are
afoot we have no idea that being said we
will see you all in 2022 thanks for
hanging out we'll see you then bye guys